That's very cool.
Three,
two,
one.
Yeah.
A guy named was his online twitter or
instagram handles tgt studios and he
makes these.
I actually had one made for Elon.
Elon Musk loved it too,
so we made him one when he made one with
like this very beautiful redwood and
those are one of those things.
May Not have jamie the some diodes or
something.
Nixey tubes.
Tubes.
The old.
Yeah.
He has to get them from Russia.
That's a.
He has them delivered over from Russia.
So they might have like listening
devices implanted in the most.
Well,
so Brian,
good to see you,
man.
Great to be back.
Yeah.
Great to have you back.
So tell me about this tour that you're
doing.
It's a,
it's a world.
Try to keep this soccer like a fist.
There you go.
How's that?
That perfect.
Yeah.
So we'll tour starts next week
and I'm the UK and then we go everywhere
from the South Island in New Zealand all
the way to the Arctic circle to
Svalbard,
which is North,
the furthest north that you can go on a
commercial aircraft in the middle of
where in the states for a month in a
mainly may and uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's about cosmology and about the
questions that cosmology raises.
So Abo,
interested in the science of how did the
universe begin,
even questions of what may have been
there is a universal eternal.
Is there such a thing as before the big
bang.
What is the future of the universe?
How does complexity emerge spontaneously
in a universe.
And then we sort of take it for granted
that we,
there's a big bang and it's all heart
and there's just this kind of hot glow
of stuff.
And I altered that spontaneously in 13
point 8 billion years.
You get something like the earth with
the civilization and life on it.
So how does that,
do we know anything about that?
I mean,
we do.
I'm asking the question rhetorically.
We know quite a lot about it,
so it's,
it's really about showing the size and
scale of the universe,
but addressing those questions I think
everybody has about what is it,
what does it mean to be human?
This tiny little finite life that we
lead in a possibly infinite universe.
How do you make sense of that?
Well,
it's incredibly exciting to me that
there's a giant audience for this and
that what Neil degrasse Tyson had been
doing and what a lot of public touring
intellectuals are doing now,
they're doing these giant theaters and
these people are coming out to see these
shows and we're realizing that there's.
I mean,
I hate to use the term market for this,
but there's a demand for this and
there's a lot of people who are
incredibly fascinated by this and it's
spreading information and spreading
knowledge.
Yeah.
I mean in the UK particularly,
I've been to Wembley arena.
For example,
you know,
you're talking about 10,000 people,
12,000 people in the shows and you're
right,
they are coming.
I'll the big shows,
spectacular screens and all that.
They're coming full to think that they
come into here about what we know
about the universe and nature and I
think,
you know,
I think I'm not surprised people are
interested because these are questions
that everybody asks.
You don't to just why am I here?
You know,
everybody's sat there asking that
question,
but I,
my point is that there is a framework,
there's a framework of knowledge,
there are things we know about the
universe,
so it is true that science scientists
are not going to tell you why you're
here and you're not to say what the
meaning of life is,
but there is actually a,
there are things you need to know if you
want to start to explore those questions
for yourself.
You need to know that there are 2
trillion galaxies in the observable
universe.
You need to know the Milky Way Galaxy
has got 200 billion stars.
Most of those stars now we know have
planetary systems.
We estimate there are something like 20
billion earth like planets or
potentially earth like planets in the
Milky Way galaxy alone.
So if you're asking questions about what
is my place in the universe,
you need to know those things.
First of all,
it's a framework within which you can
think when you get to those numbers,
when you're talking about trillions and
billions and all those zeros,
my brain just goes numb.
I,
there's this lack of comprehension that
I'm well aware of.
Like those numbers get thrown about.
I go,
oh,
$200 million now.
And I think everybody does.
I think every scientist that no
scientist can picture that number.
I mean he even the small number $200
billion,
the number of stars in one galaxy.
And then when you say 2 trillion
galaxies,
you know that that's.
I challenge anyone to be able to picture
that.
But it is the reality that we've
observed.
We've,
you know,
we,
I mean we haven't counted all 2 trillion
by the way we have.
We have a thing called the Sloan digital
sky survey,
which maps the positions of galaxies.
So you can,
you know,
how much should the sky you surveyed and
you know how many galaxies you've
counted and then you can spread that
across the wider universe and you get
this picture of a vast and possibly
infinite universe meet.
We,
we know that the universe or very
strongly suspect that the university is
much bigger than the piece we can see.
So we have good reason to think that's
the case.
Whether it's infinite or not is another
question.
And then that goes to your,
you know that.
Can you picture infinity while no one
can picture infinity?
This is a weird thing as well about,
you know,
we,
we say the universe began 13 point 8
billion years ago.
So that's a measurement.
So because we can measure the speed that
all the galaxies are flying away from us
essentially.
And then you can run time backwards if
you like.
So to find out when they were all on top
of each other.
And so it's quite a simple measurement
and we've done that.
So we say the universe began 13 point 8
billion years ago,
but actually all we know really was the
universe was very hot and very dense at
that time and we have some theories that
the universe was in existence before
that and perhaps some sort of
circumstantial evidence and that means
that actually the universe could,
could have always been their eternal.
And um,
when,
when I tell it to people sometimes they
get a bit,
some people got upset about that.
Some people would rather it had a
beginning.
The idea that it might have been around
forever is more frightening somehow.
Then the fact that it began.
It's,
it's interesting the way people's minds
work.
What terrifies you the most and eternal
universe or a finite universe?
Yeah.
Other,
both incomprehensible.
The eternal universe.
W,
if there was an eternal universe,
is that negate the theory of the big
bang or does it mean that there's a
constant cycle of big bangs and then
expansion and then recompression or
could do say those theories that are
back in vogue.
Some of those theories are back in vogue
again.
So yes,
some of them say that there's a cycling
universe,
um,
so the big bang is an event when space
gets very hot and very dense and filled
with particles.
And that may happen again,
are some of the other theories.
Uh,
there's a theory called eternal
inflation,
which is a theory that,
and it's actually the most popular
theory,
I think at the moment,
but what happened,
but why the big bang is the way that it
is who's got some very special features,
the Big Bang,
which we could talk about,
but inflation is the idea that space
space time was around before the big
bang and it was expanding extremely fast
and there was doubling in size in the
most popular of these theories.
Every 10 to the minus 37 seconds,
which is point naught,
naught,
naught with 37 knots,
one of a second.
So he's an imaginably fast expansion.
And then the idea is that draws to a
close,
so quite naturally sort of dies away and
the expansion slows down and all the
energy that was taken there was causing
that expansions sort of gets dumped into
space.
And heats it up and makes particles and
that's what we call the big bank and
those theories that slight extension to
those and say that that that slowing
down just happens in little patches.
So most of the universe,
the overwhelming majority of the
university still inflating that insane
sort of speed and they're just little
patches stop and they are big banks.
So you get multiple universities,
a multiverse,
it's called the inflationary multiverse
and we are in one of those bubbles and
that's one of the more popular theories.
Dad's another one.
I mean that right now,
aware of what you're saying.
I,
I can,
I can sort of visualize it in some sort
of a graphic form,
but it's incomprehensible like my mind
doesn't.
It doesn't have the capacity to expand
the,
the sense of distance and size to that,
that grass is this because of just the
way we evolved.
We evolved here on earth to deal with
the space.
It's in front of us and now over the
course of an industrial civilization and
education,
we are now grasping these concepts that
are so alien to the reality,
the tangible reality that we exist in
every day.
I'm sure that's
right.
And the,
the,
you know,
even very simple things like you go back
to the Greeks.
So Aristotle and the great,
you know,
very clever people,
but they thought the earth was the
center of the universe.
Why?
Because it feels like it's at the
central is it feels like we're not
moving.
Um,
and that's quite a deep point actually
in physics.
It's like why is it that we're flying
around relative to the sun very fast at
whatever speed is 18 miles a second or
something like that.
And the whole solar system is going
around the Milky Way Galaxy and so on.
Why is it that we don't feel it?
And then the Greeks quite naturally
said,
well,
because we're at the center of the
universe,
they also said everything falls to the
earth.
So therefore the earth has to be at the
center is natural.
And,
and actually it's quite a deep a
thought,
so to understand why it doesn't feel
that we're moving,
you have to go all the way to Einstein
really for someone to take that very
seriously.
And he why he said actually he said,
well,
this,
um,
there's a great little explanation in
Stephen Hawking's brief history of time
about this,
that the idea that you can't tell
whether you're moving or not demolishes
the notion of absolute space.
So if we think about space space to you
or most people,
I suppose you'd think it the way that
Newton didn't have a big box within
which things happen.
And that's got to be,
that's a natural picture of space and
the universe isn't,
it isn't a thing in which all the
planets and galaxies are placed.
But,
um,
in,
in the brief history of time harking
says,
well,
imagine bouncing a ball.
So he bends a bowl at the table,
now a tennis ball.
So I drop it and I catch it again.
Um,
so let's say I drop it and it takes a
second to bands up.
So in that second,
the earth has moved about 80 miles or so
in space around the sun.
So you could ask the question,
did that ball returned to the same place
in space or not?
And the answer is you can't answer it
you.
It does from our perspective.
But from the perspective of someone
watching the earth go all the way
around,
the sudden it went up,
I caught it again.
It had moved 18 miles and then from some
other perspective it would have been
something else.
So the point is you can't say this is a
point in space,
it came back to the same place because
that just depends on your perspective.
Depends on whether he watching the
sudden the earth around the sun or
whatever it is.
So.
So Einstein said that means there's no
such thing as absolute space,
which is kind of follows if you think
about it.
But that's a difficult.
It's,
it's cool.
Put difficult thought process,
right?
I mean that's,
that's essentially what's happening when
you're on a plane.
I mean,
if you're throwing a ball up in the air
and catching it on the planes,
having another much smaller scale,
right?
Yeah.
I mean you're flying at whatever,
600 miles an hour relative to grand,
but when you're sitting there,
yeah,
and Einstein elevated that to a
principal and said,
if you're moving it but it'd be not
accelerated and you just moving at a
constant speed in a plane or now.
I mean that's essentially what we're
doing.
Now.
We're moving around the sun that
effectively constant speed.
Then you can't tell,
so there's no experiment you can do.
We could look at the decay of
radioactive nuclear,
saw some electricity and magnetism or
Banzel have a pendulum,
whatever it is,
and there's no experiment you can do to
tell you whether you're moving or not.
Therefore,
that concept has no meaning because you
can't measure it
and that that's led Einstein to
relativity so that that's the basis of
general relativity,
which is our best theory of the
universe,
don't.
Why is it that we think that the known
universe is larger than what we can
observe?
Well,
one point is that it's an expanding and
we always see the same radiation out
there,
so the glow of the big bang,
but there is some deeper reasons.
Um,
the one from the theory of inflation,
the,
the best way to explain the universe,
the properties that we see is that it's
very much bigger than the piece we can
see.
So for example,
we measure space to be what's called
flat.
I don't even have to say what's called
flattery is flat.
So if you imagine slices of space,
let's imagine slicer to them at
different times.
So,
so you just sliced the universe and say
there's a big sheets like this,
like a tesla sheet of space and there's
another sheet and another sheet.
And it can,
it can have a geometry,
right?
It can be flat,
like a table top or it could be curved
like a sphere or it could be curved in
the opposite direction,
sort of like a saddle or a bowl.
And we can measure that.
And when we measure it,
we see it,
it's absolutely flat and that's a very
unusual thing for it to be like,
um,
it requires because what Einstein's
theory says is that the shape of space
that the curvature of space and
determined by the stuff that's in it,
that's,
that's basically Einstein's theory of
general relativity put stuff into space
and it curves it and bends it in warp
and stretches it and so on.
And what we find is that with this
precisely the right amount of stuff in
the universe to have a completely flat
universe.
And the,
the,
the explanation,
the most favored explanation for that is
university is way bigger than the piece
we can see.
And so it's like looking at a piece of
the earth.
Are you looking at little one Mile
Square of the earth?
Right?
Then it's,
it is flat,
right?
You have to look at big distances.
It's kind of avoided the radius of the
earth or you know,
bigger,
bigger than one kilometer anyway,
on one mile to see the.
Actually you're on a curved surface.
And that's one of the ideas about the
universe.
And white appears to be the way that it
is because it's way,
way bigger.
So we were just looking at a little
piece and that's why it looks flat.
And that's one of the ideas.
Now when you say flat like that,
my brain doesn't understand this because
from our perspective,
when you look up at the Milky Way,
you see all these stars all over the
place.
So if you're saying flat like a what,
how much height and what,
what are you saying?
So terms of like the way to measure it,
the best way to think about it is not to
think of three dimensions of space
because then we can't picture it.
But you can think of to like this table
top.
And that's all right.
We just forget the other one for now.
And so you know what flat is on this
table?
I mean you could define it.
So you could say for example,
that if I draw a triangle on the top of
the table,
then all the angles add up to 180
degrees.
So that actually defines flat.
If you did that on the surface of the
earth with the big triangle,
then the angles wouldn't adopt 280
degrees and all.
You could draw a circle and say what's
Pi?
So Pi is the ratio of the circumference
of a circle to its diameter.
That's only true on a flat surface is
different if the surface is curved.
So you can define flatness,
so when you.
But when you're saying flatness,
how,
what is the height and what is the
width?
Like if you're talking about it as if
it's a table,
there must be some sort of A.
There's a dimension to it,
correct?
Oh yeah.
There's a third dimension of space,
but the same applies.
It's just a generalization of geometry.
Then say you can pick fights.
We can picture it in two dimensions,
but you can.
You can draw.
You can quite literally,
you could imagine sending light beams
out and we do this measurement.
Actually we can look at the disc.
The most distant light we can see,
which is something called the cosmic
microwave background radiation,
which is if you imagine looking out,
if you look at the Andromeda Galaxy,
which we can see with the naked eye here
in la,
you can see that,
so the most distant object you can see
with the naked eye and it's about two,
2 million light years away or so,
which means the light took 2 million
years to get to us.
So it's a long way away,
but it's very big.
So it as you look further out into the
universe to more and more distant
galaxies,
you're looking further back in time
because you look at something that's a
billion light years away.
Then the light took a billion years to
get to us.
So you see it as it was a billion years
in the past and we can actually look so
far out that we can see almost back to
13 point 8 billion years ago,
which is very close to the big bank.
So we can look to light.
That began its journey before they were
galaxies and that's the the oldest light
in the universe.
Which is,
by the way,
one of the,
one of the pieces of evidence from
people say,
I don't believe in the big bank.
The answer is,
well,
you can see it.
Sorry,
I just dare,
you can see it.
We have pictures of it and that light,
it turns out that there are such
structures are ripples in that light,
um,
which we can use as a ruler.
So quite literally as a ruler on the
sky.
And then because that light has been
traveling through the universe,
we can see how that rule has been
distorted as,
as the lightest traveled through space.
And so we can infer where the space is
flat or curved or how it's warped,
if you like.
Just from that measurement is the
beautiful measurement.
Is it possible that in the future we'll
be able to see past 13 point 8 billion
years?
Not with light,
not because.
Well,
the picture is that before it's actually
released 300,
80,000 years after the big bang.
It's a very precise number.
You might say.
How do you know that?
Well,
before that time,
the universe was so hot,
the atoms couldn't form,
so you had a soup of electrically
charged particles if just too hot for
electrons to go into orbit around
Nuclei,
so the universe was opaque to light,
so you just couldn't.
It was like one,
almost like a big glowing star if you
like,
and then when it was expanding,
it cooled past the point where the atoms
could form and at that point it becomes
transparent really almost instantly and
it cosmic time scale and so the light
could then travel in straight lines
through the universe and we can see that
light so we see the light from that
time,
but further back than that,
it's opaque.
So you can't see past that with light,
but you can potentially with
gravitational waves,
which is this measurement that got the
Nobel prize a couple of years ago.
The ligo experiment here in the United
States and that seat looks for ripples
in the fabric of space and time.
And in principle,
if we had a big enough detector,
you could see the ripples from the big
bang.
So you could.
If you could take an image of the big
bang in gravitational waves,
which will be,
but you need an enormous space based
detector that we're not gonna build
anytime soon.
No,
obviously this is all through equipment
and technology that's been invented over
the last few hundred years and
perfected.
Is it possible that things could get
better and you could get some some
ability to detect things even in a far
more distant way?
Yeah.
I mean the gravitational waves are
incredible.
I mean Einstein predicted them in 1915.
Never thought they'd be detected because
you need such a high unit.
Lasers for didn't have lasers,
but they think Lygo this experiment,
which is half in a near Seattle in
Washington state and half in Louisiana,
so they've got two detectors and they're
basically sort of a a no three mile long
laser beams and that just sit and
measure this of stretching and squashing
of space as the ripples in the fabric of
the universe to go through and what
they've been observing.
Collisions of black holes,
so you can imagine how extreme a
colliding black holes.
He said incredibly extreme event,
so it shakes the fabric of the universe
and the referrals come across the
universe and these laser beams,
we should just basically,
rulers can detect it.
They just sort of ring,
just vibrate as the referrals go through
in space and time.
That kip Thorne,
he got the Nobel prize last year for.
This is one of the greatest living
physicists I was signed.
Describe it as a storm in time,
so you've got this time to storm.
It's a beautiful image.
So that technology is incredible because
the change in length is that kind of
been the exact number,
but it's way,
way,
way less than the diameter of an atomic
nucleus.
So the change in length of the beams.
It's tiny measurement,
but we can do it.
So this collision of black holes,
the idea that you can detect that?
Yeah,
that.
they did.
I said the paper,
the first paper they published that two
black holes and they were about 30 times
the mass of the sun each and they're all
beside each other and spiraling in
towards each other and they accelerated.
At one point.
They were approaching each other at one
third,
the speed of light and the accelerated
to two thirds,
the speed of light in a 10th of a second
and now hit each other and the
explosion,
the energy release was,
I think I'm right,
it was something like 50 times the
energy release that the power of all the
stars in the observable universe glowing
and it was something like 50 times and
that of energy for a tiny fraction of a
second,
but it's,
it's an unimaginably violent event and
that's why our detectors can see the
ripples that that makes in space and
time.
And we detected kind of it's two or
three of them now and also two neutron
stars colliding.
We saw that as well with it.
So it's an incredible machine,
which is why he got the Nobel prize.
Now there's a supermassive black hole.
The center of every galaxy.
Yeah.
There is also other black holes that
aren't necessarily in the center of
galaxies.
So these little ones were little,
a few times the mass of the sun and
they're from collapsed hours.
So they are stars at the end of their
life.
Very bigness and more massive than the
sun,
but they run out of their fuel and they
start to collapse because gravity
squashes them and if they're
sufficiently massive,
then there's nothing that can stop the
collapse and so they collapse as far as
we know to a point,
right?
Essentially an infinitely dense point.
We don't really know what happens that
we don't know what happened right in the
middle,
but they collapsed to such an extent
that there's a region around it where
from which light contest game and that's
a so nothing can escape and that that's
a black hole.
And what happens to them?
Do they travel?
They moving through space?
Yeah,
they'll still stars.
So they're still there.
They're surrounded this region,
wherever you fall in,
it's called the event horizon and if you
go across that horizon,
then you are going to the center.
There's one way of thinking about it,
which is quite cool.
Which is that at the time and space sort
of flip is one way to think about it.
So in the same way that we are going
into the future now,
so.
So we're going to tomorrow.
There's nothing we can do about it.
We are going to tomorrow.
I'm in the same way.
If you fall in cross the event horizon
of a black hole,
you are going to the middle,
the singularity,
it's called,
so that's,
that's your future.
Every.
Every line of your future points to the
center of the black hole.
So it's kind of the ultimate of no
escape for the ultimate prison.
You're going to get squashed to an
infinitely dense.
So point not every star becomes a black
hole at the end of its life now because
if,
if I'm sensing light the sun and we have
a small stock,
it's quite small.
Yeah,
and when it collapses,
there's A.
There's a sort of a pressure force if
you like,
which is caused by the fact the
electrons don't like to be very close to
each other,
so it's called the Paleo exclusion
principle,
but essentially what happens is that
says they get squashed closer and closer
together.
They move faster and faster to get out
of each of this way if you like.
And that makes a force which holds them
up.
And so that creates what's called a
white dwarf star,
so you can have a blob of Matzoh.
They're about the size of the earth,
but they're about the mass of the sun.
And uh,
so that's,
that's for smaller stars.
They end up as these white dwarf things
which are very dense objects as another
version which is called a neutron star,
which is the same thing,
but for neutrons and they,
they move faster and faster.
So if it's,
if it's massive enough that it
overwhelms the electron thing,
then the electrons sort of crush into
protons and turned into neutrons.
And the whole thing starts again.
And so a neutron star can be,
you know,
elite one and a half times the mass of
the sudden,
let's say.
But it can be about what,
10 miles across.
So,
so that's an incredibly dense ball of
matter held up by this neutrons moving
around.
It's got a fancy name,
it's called Neutron degeneracy pressure
with it.
But if you go even bigger than even that
can't hold it up.
And as far as we know them,
there's no known force that we know of
that can hold,
hold the thing up if it's too massive.
And so that's when it just almost winks
out of existence.
If you like it,
it collapses and collapses and
collapses.
And,
and that's when you get a black hole.
We try to put that into perspective of
the earth.
The Sun is a million times bigger than
the earth in this.
This neutron star is,
would you say one and a half times the
mass of the 10 miles wide?
Yeah.
So,
and there's loads of those around them.
They're called sales.
So we see those all over the place
there.
The first one that was discovered was
called LGM one because they're spinning
very fast.
And then the,
it was called lgm one because it's a
very irregular pulse and they thought it
was a little green men.
So they called it kind of jokingly
little green men one.
And um,
so yeah,
we,
we've seen that there's one called the
crab pulsar,
which is in the crab Nebula,
which we saw the supernova explosion.
So that's when a lot of the styles
explodes at the end of its life and then
collapses to form a neutron star.
And we saw that in 10:54 add,
wasn't there some speculation that our
gout or our solar system at one point
was,
had,
it was a binary star system and that one
of those stars had become a door.
I don't know.
Um,
some,
someone had said something about that in
relationship to the dense object they
believe is outside the Kuyper belt.
Yeah.
I mean there's some evidence that the
bits of evidence that there's something
out there.
Yeah.
And could,
because of the periodic extinctions and
things on earth,
you get periodic bombardments from in
the belt.
So yeah,
I think one of the theories,
histrionic extinctions.
Well,
yeah,
so figuring out like the,
you know,
they've been.
There had been mass extinctions on earth
when a lot of the life died and then we
don't know what caused all those.
But um,
sometimes there are impacts from space
that seems clear.
And so yeah,
there are theories that there's
something over tonight which can disrupt
all these objects are in the pipe,
the belt that sends low to comets and
asteroids inwards to the inner solar
system and can cause a habit.
And so there's some people look at those
theories.
I mean,
I don't know,
it's one of those,
it is a possibility that the same as the
circulation was,
that there's something out there is the,
correct me if I'm wrong,
something called the galactic shelf like
that it gets to a certain space and it
indicates that there's something far
larger out there.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean I think,
I don't know the exact about the stellar
sized or mass objects out there.
I don't know that.
I mean there is some sort of
suggestions.
Is another planet out there,
big planet for example.
But you're right,
there can be the be stuff in way beyond
the bell and we talk in,
you know,
a light year away or something like
that.
Now it's interesting because it's
incomprehensible the distance,
right?
And in our minds how far that must be
out past what we used to call Pluto,
but for whatever reason that becomes
more interesting because it's in our
neighborhood.
Whereas if they find some distant star
system and that it might have a planet
similar to Earth,
that doesn't seem as compelling for
whatever weird reason now.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think the planets around Alpha Centuri
approximate Centura,
which is the closest stars.
It seems like there are planets around
those now.
And then that,
that was interesting because we could
conceive of go in there and there was
this idea,
you're Stephen Hawking actually and some
others at before he died,
had this idea called breakthrough
starshot,
which is the idea to send a little probe
out to at the center at the Alpha
Centura system.
And it,
I think in their view,
Yuri milner as well,
the,
you know,
the entrepreneur wanting to do that.
And uh,
the,
I think he said something like a hundred
years traveled time or something with,
with the,
with our current technology.
And they pointed out that we don't do
that now.
We don't think a hundred years in the
future,
but if you go back when people were
building cathedrals,
people used to routinely start projects
that would take a hundred years to bear
fruit and so we imagine going there and
that's.
That then becomes fascinating I think
because then you've got a solar system
and know the solar system that you could
go and visit conceivably.
Conceivably.
Yeah.
I mean what kind of speed are we talking
and how long would it take to get there?
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
so it is.
I think the,
the idea was about 100 years to get
there,
so it's going four light years or so in
100 years or whatever that you would
have to essentially do what they didn't
like the Ridley Scott Alien Film and put
people into some sort of a,
Oh,
you're a robotic probe.
It wouldn't be a.
It wouldn't be possible for a crew.
Well it is,
but you have to freeze them.
Yeah.
That's always the.
When you touch your engineer's,
you had Ilan and didn't use engineers
always say,
you know,
physicists go,
well,
it's possible in principle,
so over to you,
you do it now there are no laws of
physics that tells us we can't do it,
so we just do it.
But you know,
that's a weird relationship with
physics.
Physicists and engineers.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But,
but yeah,
in principle you're right.
If you can send a little robots facial
there,
you can send a crude spaceship.
I'm of the opinion as time goes on and
augmented and virtual reality gets
better and better that it doesn't
totally make sense unless we're talking
about colonizing someplace to send
biological life to another planet and if
we can send some probe that doesn't have
to worry about the,
you know,
the biology being affected by radiation
or by the speed of travel or even buy
food,
we can send something out there and
almost be there by virtue of goggles,
virtual reality goggles or something
else.
Yeah.
You hear that in science at the moment.
Space Science.
We have this debate alive actually
because of course I'm space probes like
curiosity.
That's on Mars at the moment.
That's really cheap compared to sending
people to Mars,
and so quite often the scientists who
wants to find out about the world's will
say,
well,
we should spend it on robots.
We shouldn't spend it on people.
I think crewed space exploration is in
some ways,
I mean it's clearly true at the moment
that humans can do more than robots so
we can explore the place better for an
now.
Yeah,
but.
But I think it has to be.
It's about something else.
I mean it's about.
It's not only,
it's about living and working off the
planet,
which I think is quite persuasive
argument.
Actually.
We've.
We've already industrialized near Earth
orbit,
so it's already a multibillion dollar
industry in every communication
satellites and weather satellites,
gps,
whatever.
Yeah.
We're already up there and so learning
to live and work in space is I think a
natural extension of our,
of our civilization.
Plus the fact he taught,
so Elon or Jeff Bezos,
they point out that the amount of
resources available just slightly above
our heads is vast.
And so I remember I talked to Jeff Bezos
actually once and he,
he thinks really simply and he said
maybe for example,
in the asteroid belt,
there's enough metal,
I think to build a skyscraper side,
what is it?
Something like 800 stories tall and
cover the earth in it,
right if you want.
Now we don't want to dig that.
But his point was that the energy from
the sun is all up there.
The resources are up there.
So you could almost imagine trying to
zone the earth residential at some point
in the future to protect the planets.
And do you have a industry off the
planet,
for example.
And these sound,
it sounds like science fiction except
that now space x and blue origin,
those people have got reusable rockets.
So suddenly the economics become
sensible.
So I think it,
I think,
I think expansion is good and I think we
will expand and I think we will expand
outwards because there's not much room
left on this planet to expand.
So I think we'll do so.
But that's a whole different idea.
It's not about gathering scientific
information,
it's about a frontier.
And and all the benefits that come from
operating as a civilization on the
frontier which we have lost on the earth
because there is no from to your left.
And so I like that idea that Mars.
And when you talk about Mars,
especially with Elon He's right?
That that's the only place you can go.
So there,
there is no other planet we can go to
other than Mars.
You can go to Jupiter or Saturn,
mercury or Venus.
So if we want to go somewhere and expand
our civilization,
it has to be mild and everything's there
that you need.
So with that,
that's a different thing.
Saying that you want to find out stuff,
you're right.
If we just want to find out stuff,
then you send robots.
But as far as expanding actual
civilization and bring you to another
place,
one of the things that freaked me out as
people get depressed about living in
Seattle,
I mean,
you,
you're going to live on Mars.
I wouldn't agree with you.
It'd be a horrendous thing is it's like
the.
It'd be like the western front.
Yeah.
It's different here.
When people cross the states,
incredibly dangerous thing to do that
when across the states they still got to
Wyoming and beautiful places in Colorado
and.
Yeah,
but it was hard.
Yeah.
I wouldn't want it to do it.
But once you got there,
there's a river and there's trout in the
river and the metals are green and I
agree with you.
Right?
I mean I'm not going to go there.
So there were vineyards and hotels and
things.
However,
it is true that there are people he
liked the challenge and what is true
about Mars?
It's interesting actually because we
know something about the history of
miles now quite a lot about the history
of Mars and it's certainly clear that
there was water almost certainly oceans,
rivers,
so and that water is almost certainly
still there.
So I would say certainly still there
where they have found large quantities
of ice now,
right?
Yeah.
So there's certainly ice.
The may even be pockets of liquid water
below the surface somewhere.
So couple that with all the minerals and
the resources that we know are there and
you have everything you need.
So that's the thing about Mars,
which is quite nice relative to
everywhere else other than the earth.
You can't go to Venus,
you just metal.
What is it?
Four hundred and something degrees and
90 atmospheric pressure as I said so,
so,
so Mars is quite nice but I wouldn't go
there.
I agree with you because it's not
gravity of Mars in relationship to
third,
I think third,
right?
Yeah,
something like that.
So it would still have a significant
weakening effect.
Like if you went to Mars and then
somehow or another in the future they
were able to get back to earth.
Yeah.
Your body would have a real problem with
that.
Right there is there is still grabbing.
It's a bit more than a third.
I can't quite remember,
but it's something like that.
But yeah,
so there's still gravity.
So there's gravity,
there's um,
some protection from the that you'd
probably want to live in the caves
actually or something like that because
there's no magnetic field there.
So it's quite high radiation
environment,
but not too bad.
It was further from the sun than we are.
It's not to the replaces a mouse,
there's a very deep critical helis which
has a big impact basin.
And at the bottom,
the,
it's so deep you could fit everest in
it.
So you put Mount Everest in the summit
of Everest,
wouldn't reach the rim of the crater.
So it says something like,
I don't know what it is,
seven miles deep or six miles deep.
So you could go there and at the bottom
the atmospheric pressure is so high that
you could just about have liquid water
on occasionally on the floor of that
crater.
And sometimes it can be 20 degrees.
Really?
Yeah,
the Celsius.
Wow.
So,
so better than
experiencing a series called,
right?
Yeah.
So it can be warmer than Minnesota.
And so there are places where it's not
horrendous on Mars.
Uh,
you know,
so the Martian is kind of really stick
in that sense,
sort of bits of it.
Do you watch those movies and shake your
head?
I like him.
I like science fiction,
you know,
so yeah.
And I sit there.
I grew up with star wars.
That was my,
when I was nine years old,
list and say,
yeah,
I'm not having this.
I didn't,
I did an argument with Neil degrasse
Tyson,
not an argument,
but a debate with him about lightsabers
ones because I claimed that they're
physically the in principle they're
possible.
Um,
and he was trying to say that they
aren't,
but they are,
would,
they'd have to loop back around because
the light's not continuing to like the
fact that it goes to a certain distance
and pauses.
We'd have to have a mirror or something,
I guess.
Yeah.
Something that's pretty be the end of
it.
Right?
That's true.
So it wouldn't,
it'd be a different kind of lights
there.
The only point I was making is that
photons,
particles of light can bounce off each
other.
So we see that in really high energy
experiments in particle accelerators.
We can collide photons together.
So my point was a bit of a pedantic
physicists one,
but he's because he.
It is true that light can bounce off.
It can hit light,
but very,
very high energy.
But when they press that button,
it goes
to a certain distance.
I wasn't,
that's engineering,
right?
I agree with you.
The distance thing doesn't mass to it.
Right.
So as you're swinging it around,
you wouldn't have the leverage of a long
thing,
so why not make it really long?
Because it wouldn't be difficult to
swing around.
Like you could stab someone with a light
saber a mile away.
That's true.
Well that's just the laser in it.
Yes.
Like why?
Why make it so short?
Ridiculous.
You have to swing.
You got to be close to hitting a person
with it.
That's a silly,
silly design.
You are picking holes correctly in the
engineering part of my.
The only point I was making is that
physics,
is that we shut him.
He's quite interested in.
Is it light can bounce off light.
Yes.
So,
but it would have,
there would have to be something that
causes it to stop at the very end.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Which will be,
you're right,
it has merit,
but he wouldn't look cool with it if
there was no kind of thing with them.
But what drives me crazy about star wars
is not the light sabers.
It's the lasers when they're shooting
the guns,
so I'm like,
why can I see that when I can't see
bullets?
This is supposed to be way faster than a
bullet.
Like why is it easy to see this?
Because it's like you can get out of the
way.
Those things they really slow.
It would be so angry.
I'd be like,
this is so dumb.
I could go warp speed in this Millennium
Falcon and travel the speed of light,
but for whatever reason,
these lasers are so slow that you could
duck out of the way of them.
That's so dumb.
And it's not only style loads.
He takes everything.
Every single film.
Does that.
Yeah.
Well it's like films,
like also I worked on one of these films
years ago.
Sunshine.
Very underappreciated movement.
Yeah,
I think so.
I think it's brilliant film,
but in that,
so they,
they asked me,
uh,
Danny said I want to do it right.
So I'll do the spacecraft without any
sand.
So when it's traveling through space,
there'll be silent and it looks shit.
It just,
when you.
It's the same when when you try and fill
the astronauts and you and they're in
zero g and they always move slowly.
It's like,
why,
you know,
you're right,
you're right.
You'd be able to move very fast did you
want.
But it looks silly.
So this kind of a,
I suppose it's what audiences have got
used to over the years.
And so in the end you have a
partner in 2001 which didn't do it
silent in 2001.
Well,
Kubrick was a stickler for science and
for him he was apparently he would do
complex mathematics in his spare time.
Left.
Fascinating guy.
That must have been.
Yeah,
I read that.
They just,
um,
someone just found it.
Interview didn't idea of the day where
he explained the ending of 2001.
I didn't say that it yesterday actually.
And it was,
it was kind of a really simple version
of it.
He just said,
well,
the super intelligent beings take him in
and put him in a zoo basically,
and watch him grow old and then sending
back to the earth as a super being.
That's the worst explanation at the end
of 2001 I've ever heard,
but it was Kubrick's.
That's what cubic said,
so that he falls into the monolith.
Yeah.
They just put them in this room,
which is kind of a bad version of a
French chateau or something watching
grow old and then send him back to the
earth is a super being.
Wow.
Okay.
That was Kubrick's version.
Strange.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a weird genre,
right?
Because sometimes people get things
right,
like didn't hg wells predict a,
a significant amount of scientific
inventions in the future?
Well,
there is.
I mean,
defenders.
Which one doesn't it?
There was a moon one wasn't there.
He did an agenda to the moon.
I mean he's time machine is not able to
do that.
Really worked out yet.
I think it's,
I,
I always liked science fiction.
I like Arthur c Clarke a lot,
you know,
because I think it is.
You're right.
It's a form that you can let your
imagination wander and address things.
That restriction I think.
Did you like the alien series?
I loved it.
Yeah.
So I leave when I was,
uh,
when I was at school,
he's 19,
79 and we had a school film club and in
the seventies they weren't like they are
now,
you know,
and so the first films they put on the
three films,
I was 11 and it was alien,
apocalypse now in life of Brian.
Wow.
Which I.
So that was my introduction to allow.
Well those are three great choices,
but I feel like really Scott's original
alien is probably one of the greatest
horror science fiction movies of all
time.
One of my all time favorite movies.
But I really liked the newer ones as
well.
Like I like promethium and I really
liked covenant.
The last one.
Yeah,
for ets.
I don't know,
I guess it's not the best one,
what they're trying to do with it.
The,
the whole idea of what the engineers
coming back in time and that's it.
That's why I was disappointed with it
because I thought the,
the opening is brilliant and I thought
this is just going to be brilliant.
I thought it just lost its way and it
was a disappointment because it could
have been so brilliant.
Yes,
I agree with you.
Yeah.
The beginning was fantastic,
but I think covenant was more more
exciting and.
Well,
it's also preposterous.
Like if you went to another planet,
I.
The last thing you'd be doing is just
breathing in the air.
Right?
I mean we'd have to be really cool if
there was a life on the planet,
we'd have to be really careful than a.
not to contaminate but be not to be
contaminated.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah.
There's also.
I mean,
you know,
the other thing is science fiction films
is gravity because you always give me an
alien.
You always just say the spaceships got
gravity again is only 2001.
Right where everybody floats around.
Yeah.
Because all has a spinning thing.
The spaceship has gravity and then when
you land the gravity's exactly like
earth.
Yeah.
Perfect.
But it's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I've been with what are the odds that
you would find a planet that is exempt?
Like even if a planet was one and a half
times the size of earth,
it would have far more gravity.
Right.
And that's,
that's really common for a planet to be
like just a little bit bigger.
And then we will be like,
fuck everywhere it'd be walking.
We'd be,
we'd be getting crushed.
Right.
I agree with you.
Yeah.
Well I suppose that's not the point.
It's about ideas,
isn't it?
Science class and you know,
this whole idea where you just supposed
to let it,
let the,
you know,
let the story play out and.
Well,
I mean sunshine was um,
you know,
the,
the premise is,
is silly.
I mean it's,
the premise is the son is dying and
we're going to go and fix it.
Yeah.
Both of those things.
It fails on its first line in incentive
reasons,
but the idea is that it's not about
that.
It's about,
it's about the,
it's about the sun as a god in some
ways.
So it's about our response to the power
of nature and it's about day fighting
this thing and worshiping it and how
ultimately you go mad if you remember
the film,
the pin backer,
who's the first captain that went to the
captain,
the first mission to go and restart the
sun,
which is the mad bit,
but then became a religious
fundamentalist essentially,
and then decided it's a fascinating idea
that he decides to to bring meaning to
his life.
He will become the last,
last man,
the last human,
and so he wants to be the lest he wants
the son to die and he wants to take
humanity with it and he decided to make
that happen.
So he stays there waiting for the second
ship.
And I like those ideas that,
you know,
what,
what's your reaction to the power of
nature this afternoon?
One of the thing to do my shows,
I'm not being a commercial person,
I've just thought of it.
One of the great things about
cosmologies that it is terrifying in
the,
in the truest sense of the word mean.
We talked a bit about the size and scale
of the universe and black holes
colliding and those things,
you know,
it is very frightening,
but also the I think the act of trying
to understand our place in nature and
the size and scale of the universe and
now our tiny presence within it is
valuable.
It's a,
it's a so that you can be terrified but
also inspired and interested and it's
part of if you want to find,
if you want to ask questions about what
it means to be human and means to be
alive,
then I think you find the answers in
confronting that reality,
which is that we live in a terrifyingly
vast universe.
Pat,
the powers in the universe that we
cannot comprehend as you said,
but that,
that that's what you've got to face
because that's reality,
so you can't hide your head in the sand
and just duck it and it sends them.
It can send some people crazy.
I'm sure it is really interesting that
we need that suspension of disbelief in
order to sort of make a film on space.
You almost have to like go,
well this isn't really how it would be,
but this is how you have to make it in
order to fit it into a two hour movie.
Yeah.
And then the film as we sunshine becomes
about your.
Then you can have the film about
something else.
Yes.
[inaudible].
It's not really that well.
Did you like a event horizon?
Yeah,
I did actually.
I thought that's ridiculous.
I'm saying I always wanted to ask about
their,
their concept of propulsion that you
almost like space would be flat,
you would fold space over and you would
intersect those two points and you'd be
able to travel vast distances
instantaneously.
Right.
And I'm doing a terrible job of
explaining it,
I'm sure.
But is that a concept that people have
actually considered?
Yeah,
you can in general relativity.
So.
So Einstein,
I should say.
Well it is Einstein's theory of general
relativity is our best theory of space
and time and so it really is,
as we've talked about before,
it's you imagine space and time as a
sheet.
Just imagine it as a thing,
literally a sheet surface and all the
theory says is that if you put matter
and or energy into that,
then it curves it and distort it and it
can stretch it and make it shrink.
And so it's the response of space and
time to matter and energy.
So if you,
if you,
the simplest version will be the sun.
So you put the big spherical ball of
stuff in there and it warp space and
time searched at the nice straight
lines,
something just traveling minute.
So in business through that warp space
turns into an orbit and that's why you
can actually kind of see things that are
behind the sun.
Yeah,
so light bends around the sun because
it's just traveling through the curved
space.
The earth goes around the sun because
it's just rolling,
minding its own business through the
curve space.
So an example would be,
you might say,
well how does curb space,
how can connect,
give rise to something?
It looks like a force,
which is gravity.
So the best analogy I know of is to
think of walking around on the surface
of the earth to be stand on the equator
of the earth and you with your friend
and you say,
we're going to do north.
So we're going to set off,
let's say we're a thousand miles apart
on the equator and we're gonna walk due
north and what's going to happen?
So you walk in straight lines,
you don't change direction,
you don't do any accelerating,
but the straight lines and lines of
longitude on the surface of the earth.
So as you go further and further north,
you get closer and closer together and
he carried onto the pole.
You bump into each other,
but nothing's happened and no one's no
one.
There's no forces acting.
It's just that you're moving on a curved
surface and so you get closer.
And that's basically Einstein's theory
of general relativity.
Now,
why did I start talking about event
horizon?
The idea of a full.
Oh yeah.
So,
so you can.
So all you have to do,
so those folded kinds of geometries is
you have to try and specify hat where
you would put the matter and what kind
of stuff you'd put there to make the
geometry fold in that way.
And you can do,
you can do it so you can.
You can write down that geometry is
called a warp drive.
Geometry I think is called that is in
textbooks.
So you can do that too.
To have a warp drive.
The question becomes what sorts of stuff
would you have to actually put into the
real universe to make it warp in that
way.
And it always usually turns out that
it's the kind of stuff that doesn't
exist,
but it has properties.
Is Matt sort of matter or sort of energy
that has properties that do not exist in
nature as far as we can tell,
but you can still write the geometry
down in Einstein's theory.
So if you had the sadness,
guilt force or mass or whatever it is,
if you had that stuff that doesn't
exist,
it is a concept that.
Yeah.
So the geometry exists is so you can.
You can,
you can do it and you can do the
calculations and you can see the walk
drive,
you can construct wormholes that connect
distant regions of the universe,
which you could use as time machines and
you can do all that in the theory,
but in nature you'd have to have the
right stuff to do it,
but that stuff is not real.
That seems to be as far as we know now
what would have to happen,
like you would have to have enough power
or mass to be able to fold those two
things together.
It tends to be weird stuff like,
um,
stuff that has a negative pressure or
something like that.
So stuff that has physical properties
that are just bizarre and that no matter
or energy that we know of in the
universe has so that to make,
to make the geometry happen.
But it's conceivable in theory that this
could exist even though it doesn't.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a dba ultimately.
Um,
so wormholes that a good example.
So that would be quite literally it.
We talked about the surface of the
earth.
So you fly to Australia from La and you
have to go quite a long way around the
edge of the earth or you could turn or
straight through and get there quicker.
So you get that.
That's a word.
Jamie's got a little graphic up there
and there it is.
So you could go all the way around the
edge or you could take the shortcut.
So the question is,
so you can do that in theory,
you can write down that geometry and
there it is.
So the first question is can you make
it?
And as we've said,
we don't think that stuff exists.
There's a second set of theoretical bits
of theoretical work,
which if you had a worm hole then what
would happen if you tried to travel
through it and what seems to happen is
that is that they become unstable the
moment anything tries to go through.
So you get kind of a feedback of stuff
going through and through and through
and through and so it collapses and that
there's a great.
There's a great book by Kip Thorne
actually we just mentioned him.
He got the Nobel Prize last year for the
gravitational waves and he wrote a
brilliant book,
things in the eighties called black
holes and time warps way talks about
the.
The answer is we don't fully know,
but most physicists thing that even if
they existed,
they will be unstable and as soon as you
even tried to transmit information
through them,
send a bit of light through,
then there will be sought feedback and
they'd collapse.
And ultimately the reason we don't
really know absolutely is because you
need what's called a quantum theory of
gravity and we don't have one,
so we don't have the theoretical tools
to be absolutely sure that these things
would be unstable or don't exist in
nature,
but we strongly suspect that they don't.
If they did,
you could build a time machine.
So there Stephen Hawking wrote a paper
called the chronology protection
conjecture,
um,
and conjectures the important word.
So he,
at the conjecture basically was that the
laws of nature will be such that you
can't have stable wormholes and you
can't build time machines.
And if you send something through it,
it would destabilize it.
And if it didn't destabilize it,
how would your physical body deal with
the stress of that?
Well,
it doesn't have to be that you can.
You can build them.
That's called the tidal gravitational
force.
So it's the difference in gravitational
pull across your body because you.
One of the things that gets you to fall
into a black hole,
so before you actually get to the
singularity you can get is called
Spaghetti fight.
So you get there and it's just like the
moon's,
you know the tidal effects on the earth,
which is quite small,
but they still raised hides on the
oceans.
So that can be.
If you think about something like a
black hole,
that can be any massive difference in
gravitational pull from your head to
your feet.
And so it can stretch you out.
And so what you can with wormholes you,
you can,
you can write the geometry down the
United States theory such that you could
go through so you don't have to be
destroyed or anything weird happened to
you.
Would you have to have some something
protecting you?
Some force,
some,
some sort of a.
You just literally eat,
fall through.
I mean it's so,
so you know,
if they were,
they were,
they exist.
You just,
you just go through,
you sit in a little spaceship but you,
you,
you wouldn't.
There's nothing inherently in them that
says that you will be ripped apart or
anything like that.
But what are your thoughts on,
on alien life,
on life outside of this planet as
something you think about?
Yeah,
I think there must be.
I'm even in the solar system,
I would not be surprised if we find
microbes on Mars are sort of the moons
of Jupiter or Saturn where there's
liquid water like Europa.
Yeah,
and the reason is that if you think
about.
The reason I think that guests is
because if you look at the history of
life on earth,
then so earth formed and it was just a.
There was no life.
It was a ball of rock an almost.
As soon as it cooled down,
we see evidence of life.
So certainly three point 8 billion years
ago,
possibly even further back than that.
We see evidence of life on earth.
So somewhere along the line,
geochemistry,
active geochemistry became biochemistry
on earth and we have some idea,
you know,
that the,
if you get a gradient of temperature and
acid and alkaline and the conditions
that are naturally present on the
surface of oceans,
then complex carbon chemistry
spontaneously happens.
So we have a.
We know that life almost certainly we
know that life began on earth.
I mean the other opportunity came from
space or something like that,
but probably didn't really properly
began on earth.
And so that means that at least here
that happened and we know that the
conditions that lead to the origin of
life on earth were present a miles three
point eight,
4 billion years ago.
And we know that they're present on
Europa today.
So I don't see that there's anything
special.
Life is just chemistry and it and the,
the idea that geochemistry becomes
biochemistry's not fanciful because it
happened here.
So I think that given the same
conditions,
it will be surprising to me at the same
thing didn't happen in that life begins.
So I,
I,
that's one of the two tests.
That is one of the great frontiers of
science now,
which one of the great challenges,
which is why another reason we're
interested in Mars,
because we know those conditions where
there,
we know there were what's called
hydrothermal vent systems on the floors,
have oceans on Mars,
three point eight or 4 billion years
ago.
So it will be good to know what I've
said is right and the way we find out is
to find life or evidence of past life.
Are you aware of,
uh,
the speculation that was going around
with how recent was it that occupy
thing,
the,
uh,
the octopus eggs,
they,
there was a group of scientists that
were speculating that it's Panspermia
the idea of Panspermia,
that it's possible that Octopi had come
from somewhere else and frozen eggs had
actually come from somewhere else and
landed on earth.
And these are like legitimate scientists
are contemplating not morons.
I don't think I've seen this,
the,
no,
I didn't,
but I mean it.
So panspermia doesn't have to be
unlikely.
I mean,
for example,
you might have seen the other day we
found an earth rock on the mood.
Yes,
right.
Well they'll back on this now because he
apollo astronauts brought it back in the
4 billion years old or something.
One of the oldest rocks ever found.
Yeah.
So.
So we know that material
transfer between planets and so it's not
inconceivable that microbes could
survive that journey.
Right.
We know that microbes can survive in
space,
for example,
so that isn't mad.
It's probably unlikely,
but he's not mad.
But with the octopus I hadn't heard
that,
but the thing is that the octopus is
still extremely biologically
to us.
I mean the difference is negligible,
so it's still got the same energy system
with a single ATP and DNA and all that
stuff.
It's all very,
very similar.
It was something about rna and DNA.
Did you find that out?
I'm enough.
I'm looking at a different one from a
different website.
It's about the same thing.
It has to do with the Cambrian explosion
and there were 33 authors on a paper
that got published and the progress and
in biophysics and molecular biology that
talked about this possibility.
There are other people that disagree
with it though.
Right.
I suppose the,
I haven't seen it,
so I think it's unlikely because the
octopus is extremely similar to us,
so that suggests a common origin.
To me that's a pose.
The cancer argument you could,
you could advance would be there's only
one way to do life,
so you could say the actually given
because the laws of physics and
chemistry the same everywhere,
so maybe it's maybe DNA,
which is the only way to do it.
So that's the way it gets done.
Which is why they're so similar to us is
so alien as well.
Yeah,
they're not though,
you know,
that's the thing.
If not.
So that's why I'm surprised about
because they're not that alien.
They're very similar.
While they're in their abilities,
their ability to transform their texture
and their color instant almost
instantaneously.
They have incredible camouflage
abilities that really don't exist in the
mammalian world.
Yeah.
But on a cellular level,
you look at Knox for sell in among under
a microscope and you wouldn't be able to
sell the treating not for selling
humans.
So the only way that that would make
sense as if all life comes from
basically the same kind of building
blocks and just varies depending upon
the conditions and where it takes place.
I'm,
I'm guessing,
but yes,
that,
that that must be the.
The only way you could sustain that,
given that they're so similar to us
because they really are biochemically,
is that that's the only way it can be
done given the given the building block,
the toolkit,
the laws of nature and the elements and
so on that we have in our universe,
we have so many different life forms on
our planet,
but if we found anything that's remotely
similar to what we have here on earth,
on another planet,
it would be such an incredible
discovery.
Like we sat,
we found a frog on the moon.
I mean the world would stop.
Right.
I'd be very surprised if we found
anything anywhere that is any,
in any way similar.
An insect on Mars.
Well,
this is.
I mean,
as I said,
it'd be micro.
I think every single celled things
remember.
I mean you mentioned the Cambrian
explosion,
so that is that.
What we do know that earth is that
although life began,
let's say three point 8 billion years
ago,
it wasn't until around 600 million years
ago or so,
that maybe most 700 that you see any
complex multicellular organisms at all.
So if there's something like 3 billion
years,
it was single celled alone and that's
one of the reasons why I would guess if
I had to guess,
I would say that microbes would be
common because life began very quickly
on earth and I wouldn't be surprised to
find
finding on Mars,
but complex life,
multicellular life,
insects,
plants,
intelligence,
I would guess will be very rare because
it took so long on earth to get there
and you just slime bag.
Three billion years of slime.
That was it.
On what happened?
How did it go from slime?
Two giraffes.
It's very quickly once he wanted to go
in and it's one of the great unsolved
mysteries in biology that one thing that
is true is that we seem to be all
complex creatures seemed to be and we
were called.
You carry it,
writers yourselves with the cell nucleus
and all that kind of stuff and they look
like they're the merger between two
simpler life forms of bacteria and a
thing called an archaic and okay,
and so it looks like somewhere in 2
billion years ago,
whatever it was,
in some ocean,
the bacteria cell got inside the arcane
and survived as,
as a symbiotic organism essentially,
and then somehow unbelievably managed to
reproduce and replicate in that
configuration and that does seem to be
the origin of all complex,
multicellular life on earth.
So it's called a fateful encounter
hypothesis.
And if that's true then it's just a bit
of luck and it happened once.
Right?
And that's why we're here now when blind
look considerably like how many billion
earth like planets did you say exists
just in our sources to the alone in the
galaxy?
20 billion,
something like that.
So one in 10 styles.
So the odds of complex life out of our
incredibly fortunate situation,
but the odds of that occurring on any of
these billions of other planets that
exist,
we don't know,
but let's say the earth is.
Let's say it was under the fortunate
side,
so,
so we're,
we're,
we're talking about give or take 4
billion years,
right?
And the origin of life to now,
and we have a civilization now and we've
had it.
Our species has been around what,
a quarter of a million years or
something.
So it's just now basically.
So let's say 4 billion is on the
fortunate side,
let's say that it was double that or
triple that on the average.
Suddenly that's the age of the universe,
right?
That's a third of the age of the
universe.
So how many of those worlds had been
stable for three or 4 billion years?
That's quite a tall order actually.
It looks like our solar system might be
quite unusual in that respect that
because they had the planet,
it's got to remain stable in a stable
orbit.
The stars got to remain stable.
System stabilizes at Jupiter.
Plays a big role.
Takes of treatments.
Yeah,
socks and soap and that you know that
there's a thing.
There's a theory called the grand tack
theory,
which is very hard to explain the
evolution of our solar system so that
when you do compete a models of solar
systems,
you don't tend to get for rocky planets
too close to the sun and for big gas
giants.
Further out,
and one of the current best theories,
and this I say this because it shows you
how lucky we might be,
is that Jeff said that they tend to form
these big gas Jane's and migrate inwards
towards the Star.
So in almost all the computer
simulations,
just because you got this big gas giant
obits and all the dust around this star.
They tend to drop in woods and it looks
like Jupiter did that.
So it looks like it formed and came in
and came in almost to where Mars orbitz
today and cleared out the region around
Mars actually.
Which is maybe the reason Mars is so
small compared to the other to Venus and
earth.
But then Saturn was coming in as well.
And in the computer models.
The interaction between Jupiter and
Saturn Stop Jupiter coming in before it
gets to the earth.
And they both get dragged out again and
so to where they are today and so,
and that,
that seems to be,
it's one of the best theories for the
evolution of our solar system.
So what are the chances that the chances
of that are so many skill?
My tiny.
So that's the thing I think about these
rocky planets in order to get a
civilization on them.
I think you need,
I guess you need quite unusual solar
systems that will be a guest and you
need quite unusual stability on the
planet for,
for billions of years.
And that's why I think we might be quite
lucky.
Hmm.
And how does bodes law work?
Bodes laws,
a method of detecting if you look at the
mass of a planet,
you can accurately detect how much mass
and the size of a neighboring planet.
I think it wasn't just the,
um,
the physicians of the obits I think
we're in.
Yeah.
And uh,
it's one thing that is true,
but our solar system is that you,
if you get the computer simulations,
you can't put more planets in to try and
fill,
put more planets.
And they become,
it becomes unstable very quickly.
So the,
the mass of like,
if you measure Mars,
you can accurately depict where the next
planet close to it would be.
It,
it was,
I mean it was,
that's what was done was at 17th century
or something.
I can't remember his along yet.
It was just one of those things where,
you know,
it's a pattern and they were just trying
to figure out what the answer is.
Just a pattern which is,
um,
you know,
not,
there's nothing to that really other
than to say that most simulations of the
solar system,
if there are,
if you put other planet saying they tend
to get thrown out by gravitational
interactions.
So there is a sense in which our solar
system has got as much stuff in it as it
could have.
So the planets and nicely spaced and
you're right,
given the massive them,
that depends on how close to the planet
can be before the interaction goes
wrong.
And it gets thrown out into the
intergalactic space.
Something.
Because planets do that,
you know,
we,
we know that planets get thrown out of
solar systems by gravitational
interactions.
So it,
yeah.
So again,
it points to the fact that solar systems
are not a not stable over long periods
of time.
They're not like clockwork.
Things not like Newtonian clockwork and
it just goes on forever.
They're not like that,
that they evolve and planets can shift
orbitz and change and what we know,
maybe look at the surface of the moon,
for example,
it covered in craters and that was,
cause they all seem to hit about the
same time and it's about three point 8
billion years ago or so.
Uh,
and that's called the late heavy
bombardment.
So we know that if you look at cratering
and rates on Mars or the moon,
it all seemed to happen in this,
not all,
but a big peak around that time.
And that seems to be correlated with
Neptune moving outwards in the solar
system and into Kuyper belt,
basically our towards the Kuyper belt
and causing all sorts of havoc and
everything comes into the inner solar
system.
So those things happen and it didn't
happen when life was established on the
earth,
so it's all extremely old stuff that
shifting to explore.
But how long,
how long is the source system,
but in this particular stable situation
that's in it since about three point 8
billion years ago.
So if it'd been unstable at any point
since then,
then we likely wouldn't be here.
Right.
Do you think that it's possible?
Do you ever entertain the idea that it's
possible that we are the only
intelligent life in the known universe?
I,
I tend to restrict myself to the galaxy.
So I do think it's possible that at the
moment there's one civilization in the
Milky Way and that says,
and I think that's important actually.
It goes back to I was saying at the
start about the astronomy and cosmology
being part of the framework within which
you have to think if you're looking for
meaning or you're looking for how we
should behave even politically.
You know,
the that has a bearing to me.
I mean,
imagine that we're the only place where
there is intelligence in this galaxy and
how should we behave,
right?
Should we actually not withstanding the
fact that we're tiny and fragile things
an insignificant physically should we
consider ourselves extremely valuable in
that respect because there's nowhere
else where you know that I would go as
far as to say there will be nowhere else
where meaning exists in the Milky Way in
because meeting.
It's one of those things that scientists
don't talk about very much.
Although Richard Fineman,
one of my great heroes did talk about
it.
There's a quote where he says,
well,
is the meaning of it all?
It's a great essay called the value of
science,
and so what is self evidently true is
that meaning exists here because it
means something to us.
So that's kind of an obvious statement.
Your life means something to you in May
and so meaning exists,
but I think it is a local and temporary
phenomenon.
I think it's.
It emerges,
meaning emerges from configurations of
atoms,
which is what we are.
We are simply that.
We're nothing more than that.
We're very,
very rare configuration of atoms I
think,
and so that means that we are,
if you go all the way down that line of
logic,
we are the only island meaning in the
galaxy.
I will meaning only to ourselves.
Yeah.
It means something to us because we're
the only ones who can grasp the concept
and we are finite.
We are finite organism,
we have this temporary existence while
we're here and to us there is meaning.
Yeah.
And that's,
I don't know any other way to define it.
So I'll define it like that.
Yes.
I don't think there's a globe.
Yeah.
Otherwise you have to believe there's
some kind of global meaning God type
finger.
Uh,
I don't think that's.
I think it's more wonderful and more
challenging to us because we have to
take responsibility for it to say we
should operate such that we are it in
this galaxy.
There's nothing else.
I'm sure.
I'm just,
I'm sure there are other civilizations
out there in the universe because there
are 2 trillion galaxies.
I,
I just can't believe this hasn't
happened in other places.
The question is how often does it
happen?
And how widely spaced are the
civilizations and I think they're very
widely spaced and I think there may be
one or two per galaxy on the average.
I could put that as you said,
that what you said it beautifully,
that.
What else can we think?
Well,
what else do you want?
I mean,
I think what it says is you have to take
responsibility for all of those things
or spiritual things that you think about
and the emotional things you think about
it,
you,
you are,
you are responsible for that.
You are that,
that whatever that is,
it exists in you and it will only exist
for a short amount of time.
And so what you know make the best of it
will be my view.
It's so unbelievably compelling though
to consider the idea that somewhere out
there there's another civilization that
maybe even more advanced than us and
this,
this thought of it is just so
attractive.
It's,
it's incredible.
That shit should be.
If,
if civilizations are common or even
slightly common,
then there should be civilizations ahead
of us.
Yes,
because there's been so much time,
but when you want to see what that's
like,
I mean,
we've been so compelling.
You imagined the timescales.
We've been around a civilization,
let's say 40,000 years.
I don't know how long I civilization's
been around.
Let's say that the,
the,
the galaxy is pretty much as old as the
universe.
Thirteen billion years worth of time.
So the idea that there are no,
no civilization zeroes,
you know,
100 million years ago,
200 million years ago,
1 billion years ago.
And imagine what they'd be like if
they'd survived.
I mean,
we've been,
we've been around,
we've had science for let's say since
Newton or copernicus,
500 years at most we've had.
And look what we've done.
We've gone beyond the solar system with
voyager.
We've walked on the moon and we were
about to go to Mars,
I would think.
So we're about to begin colonizing our
own solar system.
And so we've done that in 500 years.
So imagine a million years in the
future.
So I would.
It's one of the arguments often used to
say,
there aren't any civilizations out there
in the galaxy.
It's called the Fermi paradox because if
you imagine a civilization that's a
million years ahead of us,
they should have written their presence
across the sky by now.
They should use to see him.
I mean,
you'll see us if we survive in million
years into the future.
Actually even a few thousand years into
the future,
we will be exploring the galaxy.
We will have spacecraft that are going
to wear the stars.
We will be doing it,
so our signature will become visible.
I'm sure if we last into the medium
term,
we choose to not do that.
Here's my thought on that is uncontacted
tribes like do you know about the.
The gentleman who was the missionary who
visited North Sentinel Island and was
killed by the natives,
north central island,
which is a really unusual place because
they branched off from Africa 60,000
years ago and they've been living on
this one small island the size of
Manhattan and as well as we know there's
only about 39 of them left somewhere
around there and um,
we can't,
we're not supposed to contact them like
people are not supposed we're supposed
to like leave them alone and there are
rare tribe when they find them in the
Amazon,
the uncontacted tribes,
our initial instincts back off and leave
them alone,
leave them alone.
Do you think that perhaps the universe,
like if there is a civilization that's a
million times more advanced than us have
been around here for,
you know,
that millions of years of life as
opposed to quarter million,
why would they,
why would they let us know?
They look at us dropping bombs on each
other and polluting the ocean,
sucking all the fish out and putting
clouds into the skies of dirt and
particles.
And why would they literally look at
these crude monkey?
So are there data there is so far beyond
where they need to be before they could
join the galactic civilization or
whatever it is.
True.
It's an argument that the reason.
Okay.
No argument
as well.
The IT technology so advanced would be
difficult for us to detect.
I mean we tend to think of know when you
say written across the sky,
I suppose it's trigger.
I'm thinking of star ships and things
like star wars,
right?
Big Energy.
Things that you can see the signature
of,
but actually maybe the.
The civilization just becomes a nano
civilization.
Tiny
little.
None of us because that's more
efficient.
It's a better way to do things.
So it's possible.
I suppose that there are space probes
all over the place.
They're so small and it's so efficient
and you sell it low energy that we just
don't see them as far as that is
possible.
My other thought is that where we are
headed,
it seems to me that there's some sort of
a strange symbiosis that's taking place.
There's a,
there's a strange connection that we
have to electronics and ultimately to an
artificial creation,
artificial intelligence,
whatever you want to call it,
artificial light life,
something that's created by carbon based
beings.
Stem cell,
you are beings that isn't cellular,
but also acts like life,
that this may be the future of life,
that we are so connected to the idea of
flesh and blood and bone,
but maybe this is just a temporary
situation until we transition or not
transition to,
it surpasses us and this is the next
stage of life,
but this stage has no need for all the
human and biological reward systems that
are in place that made sure that we
survive.
Whether it's ego or fear or emotions,
no need for that,
that it will just exist and maintain its
equilibrium as this new form of life and
that this is the future of life in the
universe and that will get there.
Maybe it'll only be 100,
200 years from now,
but that,
that that's what exists all throughout
the cosmos.
So there's no need to peacock.
There's no need to show our sand on the
sky and that it just exists in this
form.
Yeah,
I,
I agree.
I wouldn't be surprised.
Yeah.
So that's the,
that's the counter argument to the Fermi
paradox argument that I talked about
what a,
exactly as you've just said,
that basically you evolved to a point
very rapidly where you just don't create
a signature and you don't really get
involved as you said.
Maybe it just maintains,
but it has no.
Well,
there's no motivation,
right?
Like,
it doesn't.
Our motivations are so weird,
right?
We have these biological motivations to
survive and uh,
you know,
there's motivation is to conquer and to
innovate and to spread our genes and to
move into new territories.
But if you didn't have biology,
if you were,
you existed completely from manmade
materials or from materials found on
earth and that this new form of life is
created out of that.
I wouldn't have those unless you program
them.
And why would you do that?
It is interesting,
isn't it,
to two because we don't know what
consciousness is.
It's often called the hard problem in
science.
We don't know.
So it's a good question whether you can
build,
let's say you want to build a self
replicating machine,
which is what you're talking about,
something that can go and maybe go to
the moon or Mars and replicates itself
and then carry on,
which is a living thing.
I,
yes,
does he have to have a sufficient level
of intelligence that he actually is
conscious and all these things that we
talked about,
this,
this word meaning that we used earlier
that we all understand that you can't
define,
is that a emergent property that,
that has to emerge if you've got
something that's intelligent enough to
replicate itself and live and said to be
the,
I don't know the answer,
but it is worth considering that this
thing,
this what we emotion meaning love and
fear and all those things are just the
things that happen when you are
intelligent.
I don't know the answer to that,
but it could possibly be.
And does consciousness have to have our,
uh,
local origin?
Like it doesn't have to come from a
thing.
Like if you think about cellular
communication,
the,
if you send me,
if you're in England and you send me a
video from your phone and it reaches my
phone,
it's getting to meet through space.
It's going through the sky.
It's like literally from a device not
connected by any wires or anything.
It's coming to me if,
if there's a possibility to create some
sort of global intelligence through
electronics that's nonlocal.
If one piece of it falls off this same
is it just repairs itself or figures
itself out,
but it's the same consciousness existing
on a global scale through some sort of
an electronic network that instead of
the.
The idea that you and I have that Brian
and Joe are,
you have your mind.
I have my mind and we,
we exist as intelligent being separate
from each other,
but instead of that,
that all of it is connected and that all
of it is something that we can't even
conceive of because our brains are too
crude.
Like trying to explain to,
you know,
Australia Pithy,
kiss what a satellite is.
Yeah,
I mean I,
yeah.
So many of you think about our brains,
they are ultimately,
what are they?
They're just a distributed network of
cells connected by neurons and they're
very complicated,
but they are a colony of things that are
autonomous in a sense and the
communicating with each other.
So yeah,
I don't,
I don't see why you can't scale that up
in principle.
I mean,
I should just add the caveat is always
that we don't know this.
It's just not understood.
Well,
I think there's something weird
physical,
but I'm damn sure it's physical.
I'm damn sure that there's nothing going
on in my head other than what is allowed
by the laws of nature as we understand
them.
So eliminating show,
you mean the idea of a soul being some
sort of a divine thing that's inside the
housing of the body?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I would say we can rule that out
actually.
I've argued in the past.
How do you rule it out?
I valued,
we can rule that out in the following
manner.
So,
so here's my arm,
right?
So
it's made of electrons and protons and
neutrons.
And,
uh,
if uh,
if I have a soul in the,
something that we don't understand,
but it's a different kind of energy or
whatever it is we don't have in physics
at the moment,
it interacts with matter because I'm
moving my hand around.
So whatever it is,
it something that interact very strongly
with matter.
But if you look at the history of
particle physics in particular,
which is the study of matter,
we spend,
we spent decades making high precision
measurements of how massive behaves and
interacts and we look for,
for example,
for a fifth force of nature.
So we know for forces the gravity,
the two nuclear forces called the weak
and strong nuclear forces and
electromagnetism.
And that's what we know exist.
And we look for another one with ultra
high precision and we don't see any
evidence of it.
So I would claim that we know how matter
interacts at these energies.
So room temperature.
Now these,
Angie,
we know how matter interacts very
precisely and so if you want to suggest
the something else that interacts with
matter strongly,
then I would say that it's ruled out.
I would go as far to say it's ruled out
by experiment or at least he sees
extremely subtle and you would have to
jump through a lot of hoops to come up
with a theory of some stuff that we
wouldn't have seen when we've observed
how matter interacts that is present in
our bodies and presumably be believing
the soul.
You want it to exist outside.
When you die,
you still want the thing to be there and
you might believe in ghosts and things
like that.
We like a ghost.
I mean it's a.
It is something that carries the imprint
of you.
Presumably it looks like you.
So that means that interact strongly
with the matter.
That is you because it carries a
pattern.
It carries a pattern and it carries
information.
It carries information.
There has to be an energy source that
allows the information to assist in the
pattern to persistence,
so on.
So again,
you end up with a theory that is
postulating.
Something interacts with light because
if you think a ghost is the soul,
then it's something that people see
sometimes.
So that means it interacts with light.
But we know how light interacts and we
ruled out anything but the most subtle,
uh,
further interaction that we haven't
seen.
So I would,
I claim that I started off as a joke,
but it's actually,
I wrote it in an infinite monkey cage
book,
this radio show that I do,
but he ended up,
when I'd written it down,
I thought actually that it makes sense.
And I read some news similar.
Actually,
I think I'm Sean Carroll.
Lee,
I don't know if you've had shown up a
couple times.
He's said something the same.
I think in the book that he wrote the
big picture.
I think he has a similar argument
actually,
so it's occurred to him as well,
is roughly the same argument.
So if you.
So this energy that's interacting with
matter,
even if you're not moving at all,
if you're just thinking it's interacting
with the matter encompasses your
mind or your brain or your nerves and
your neurons.
It's something in there that's
interacting with matter whether you like
it or not.
So even just a simple thought process or
a dream is still something it's
interacting with Matt.
Yeah.
Well obviously because you know you,
it's your will,
isn't it?
When you move it's presumably,
but even if you're not moving the idea,
like the year you're saying you're like
your body's interacting with batteries,
you're moving your arm,
but even if you're not moving,
if you're just thinking and you're
completely still,
which is not totally possible because
your heart's beating and your breathing
and all that stuff,
but if somehow or another you were able
to isolate just the thought,
the thoughts themselves are still
interacting with matter because they're
interacting with the brain itself.
Yeah.
So there's something in there that's
something to interact with the physical
structure of your body.
And and now I would say there isn't.
So that's
the woo woo version is that the brain
itself and the body of the physical,
the spiritual self,
you are merely an antenna that's tuning
in to the great consciousness of the
universe.
But why?
But then you have to answer what we
know,
what we're made of.
So we know how those particles behave
and interact.
So.
So why did the particles not a in any
way interact with that stuff?
Because we interact,
we don't know if that's true.
We don't only just interact with it,
so we interact extremely strongly with
it.
We're interacting with it now.
Yeah.
Every movement I make is the interaction
between that.
Every man have.
Yeah.
Yes.
When everything.
If I moved my fingers or everything that
I'm doing is an interaction between that
stuff and me,
so it's a very strong interaction with
matter,
but we don't see it in all our precision
measurements.
Well,
the answer for that,
the answer is because it's not there.
The answer is Jesus and you can't
measure God.
That may be an answer,
but the point is you as we'd sell it for
earlier with absolute space,
if you can't measure it,
it's not there.
Right?
It's,
but for,
for whatever reason,
for people,
there is some incredible motivation to
find a divine something or another
that's there's something greater than
this physical being that there's
something.
What do you think that is?
Like what is that compulsion?
We.
We've already talked a bit of balance
it.
I think it goes to the the heart of this
question of what it means to be human.
So I would say that being human,
the answer to that,
I don't know the answer to the meaning
grid,
but the answer would be,
uh,
we are small finite beings,
right?
Which are just clusters of atoms as we
said before,
a very rare,
but we understand roughly how they,
how they came to be,
and we have a limited amount of time,
not actually unfortunately,
but because of the laws of nature,
the laws of nature for bidders to be
immortal,
they,
they a mortalities ruled out by the laws
of physics,
but also actually what is it?
What's interesting about if you look at
the basic physics of the universe going
from the Big Bang to where we are today,
then the physics is driven by the fact
that the universe began in extremely old
state because it was a very highly
ordered system and it is tending towards
a more disordered system at the moment
and that's called the second law of
thermodynamics.
And it's that basic common sense thing
that things go to shit.
Basically it's the second law of
thermodynamics.
What we strongly suspect,
and I would say no,
is that in that process of going from
order to disorder,
complexity emerges naturally for a brief
period of time,
so it's a natural part of the evolution
of the universe that you get a period in
time when there's complexity in the
universe,
stars and planets and galaxies and life
and civilizations,
but they are.
They exist because the universe is
decaying,
not in spite of the fact the universe is
so our existence in that sort of picture
is necessarily finite,
unnecessarily time limited,
and it is a remarkable thing that that
complexity has got so far that there are
things in the universe that can think
and feel and explore it,
and I think that is the answer.
If you want an answer to the meaning of
it all,
it's that,
that you are part of the universe
because of the way the laws of nature
work.
You are allowed to exist,
but you're allowed to exist for
temporary for a small amount of time in
a possibly infinite universe.
One of the biggest mind blowing moments,
I think,
of my limited comprehension of what it
means to be a living being was when I
found out that carbon and all the stuff
that makes us has to come out of a dying
star,
like that alone,
that there's this very strange cycle of
these enormous fireballs that forge the
material that makes Brian Cox like what?
That,
that one alone that there is some
strange loop of of,
of biological life that comes from
stars,
which is like the most elemental thing
that we can observe.
We see these things in the school.
You see the sun in the sky.
It's this all powerful ball fire and
that that is where the building blocks
for a person come from and they will be
from the carbon atoms in our body that
you're right.
They all got made in stars because there
was just none of it at the big bang.
There's only hydrogen and helium tiny
bit lithium to be precise but nothing
else,
and so it was all made in stars and it's
probably from different styles.
You know the acids in your body.
They're not all from one star that
cooked it and then died.
There'll be a mixture of stuff for many
styles in your body now,
and I agree with you.
The what more do you want?
You know,
when,
when I see people go,
I want more than that.
I wouldn't.
Yeah,
it must.
There must be more to it.
What do you mean the,
the,
the we,
we had,
we were the ingredients now voltage were
assembled in the hearts of long dead
stars over billions of years and they've
assembled themselves spontaneously into
temporary structures that can think and
feel and explore and then their
structures will decay away again at some
point,
and in the very far future there'll be
no structures left.
So.
So there we are.
We exist in this little window when we
can observe this magnificent universe.
Why do you want any more?
I think too,
people will.
I think a lot of people aren't aware of
all the,
all the information,
right?
And then I think on top of it,
for some people it's just,
it's so overwhelming this,
this concept of 13 point 8 billion years
of everything to get to this point that
we're at right now.
It's so overwhelming that they want to
simplify it and want to put it into some
sort of a fable structure.
Something where it's something that's
very common and similar and familiar.
Yeah.
I,
I agree.
Um,
and,
but I think that's the,
the is the,
the,
the journey that we go on,
the real treasure.
I think it is in that journey of trying
to face the incomprehensible.
It's in that realization that it's
almost,
it's almost impossible to believe that
we exist.
Right.
That's,
that's,
that's a wonderful thing.
Yeah.
And I think that that's what I think you
miss out.
I think if you decide to simplify it
because you don't want to face that,
you don't want to face the infinity
that's out there in front of us and you
don't want to face those stories as you
said,
that you look at your finger and it's
ingredients cooked in multiple styles
over billions of years.
That that's a.
to me,
it's a joyous and powerful thing to
think about.
Yes,
and I think you're missing out if you
don't want to face that.
Why I think the distribution of
information has changed so radically
over the last couple of hundred years
and particularly over the last 20 that
you're seeing these trends now or more
people are inclined to abandon a lot of
the.
Even if you remain religious remain you.
You keep a a thought or a belief in a
higher power.
People are more inclined to entertain
these concepts of science and to take in
the understanding of what has been
observed and documented and written
about amongst scholars and academics and
there's more.
There's more people accepting that.
Have you looked at the number of
agnostic people now as opposed to 20,
30 years ago?
It's,
it's,
it's rising,
it's changing and I think there's also
because of you and because of Neil
degrasse Tyson and Sean Carroll and all
these other people that are public
intellectuals that are discussing this
kind of stuff,
people like myself have a far greater
understanding of this than I think
people did 30,
40 years ago and that trend is
continuing,
I think in a very good direction.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
well we should say is that science,
we don't know all the emphasis,
so we don't know where the laws of
nature came from.
We don't know why the universe began and
the way that it did if indeed at the
beginning,
so it doesn't know why the Big Bang was
very,
very highly olded,
which is ultimately a show.
And Carol actually you mentioned him
often points out it means right,
that they.
The whole difference.
The only difference between the past and
the future so-called called Arrow of
time is that in the past the universe
was really old and it's getting more
disordered and that's that,
that,
that necessary state of older,
at the start of the universe,
which is really the reason that we
exist.
That's the reason cause the universe
began in a particular form.
We don't know why that was so we,
we,
we will probably find out at some point
and it'll be something to do with the
laws of nature,
but so I'm always careful.
I don't want to.
Science can sometimes sound arrogant,
right?
It can sometimes sound like it's the,
it's the discipline of saying to people
where you're not.
Right,
and it's not the discipline of saying
you are not right.
It's saying this is what we found out.
Yeah.
So it.
I,
I liked to say that it provides a
framework within which if you want to
philosophize or you want to do theology
or you want to,
you want to ask these deep questions
about why we're here.
You have to operate within that
framework because it's just an
observational framework.
So everything we've said is stuff we've
discovered,
it's not stuff that someone made up,
right?
We,
we,
you know,
we understand nuclear physics,
we can build nuclear reactors for
example,
so we understand the physics of stars.
So we understand that the styles built
the carbon and oxygen and we know how
they did it and we can see it because as
I said before,
we can,
if you look far out into the universe,
you're looking way back in time and as
you look back in time,
you see less carbon and less oxygen.
So we have a direct observation that in
the earliest universe there wasn't any
because we can see it and now we see
that there is some and we
know how it was made.
So I think it's so.
It's important to be humble when you're
talking about science and you're not
saying this is the way that it is.
I mean you are in a sense,
but it's not.
It's not able to answer ultimate
questions at the moment is not able to
answer even whether the universe had a
beginning or not.
We don't even know that.
And I gave it to,
um,
I was asked to give a talk to some
bishops in the UK about cosmology and I
said,
yeah,
that'd be great fun.
And so I went and I gave him this talk
and,
and at the end I said,
I've got some questions.
So if the universe is eternal and it
might be,
it might not have had the beginning.
If it's eternal,
what place is there for a creator?
You know,
that's,
that's a good question.
We didn't,
they didn't have an answer of course and
eternal creator,
but yet.
But I think that these,
it might be eternal and we might
discover that.
So we don't,
we don't know at the moment,
but we might.
So I think my point is that these other
human,
a decisive,
very natural to religions and natural
thing,
right?
People you see all across the world and
all different cultures.
But I think that in the 21st century it
religion needs to operate within that
framework.
If it's going,
it's going to operate.
There are still great mysteries and it
is appropriate to think about what it
means to be human and are giving you my
view of what it means,
but,
but I don't think the problem comes when
you,
when you're your theology or your
philosophy forces you to deny some
facts,
some measurement.
Now these things that measurements,
we were not saying,
it's not my opinion.
The Universe is 13 point 8 billion years
old.
We measured it.
It's like having an opinion between the
distance from La to New York that you
can't have an opinion on that.
What it is and it's the same decided
that the three things you notice is that
people say the earth is flat or whatever
that is,
or it isn't,
and we've measured it so it's just stop
it,
you know,
so,
but that doesn't mean you can't be
spiritual and you can't be really just,
I would say it doesn't mean you can't
believe in God or gods or a date that's
not ruled out by signs,
but some stuff's ruled out.
I love the way you communicate this
because it takes into consideration
human nature.
And like,
I love Dawkins,
he's fantastic,
I think he's very,
very,
very valuable,
but he likes to call people idiots.
And the problem with that is people go,
fuck you.
You're an idiot.
Like is a natural inclination when you
insult people to argue back and to sort
of dig their heels in and uh,
you don't do that.
And I think that's very important and I
think that a guy like doc has just gets
frustrated from all these years of
debates with people who are uneducated
or saying ridiculous things and he's a
bit of a curmudgeon,
you know,
when he seems to be softening as he's
getting older.
He's an evolutionary
biologist.
That's the,
the front line in some sense,
isn't it?
Yes,
it is.
To think about particle physics is that
you don't get a lot of shit because
people don't understand what you're
talking about.
Evolutionary biology is right there.
So I understand his frustration.
Oh,
I do too.
Having said that,
you know,
I've kind of softened a bit over the
years actually because now I think at
this point,
both in the US actually and in Britain
and in some of the countries we are a,
an a point you've sort of alluded to it
where everybody's angry with a lot of
anger and a lot of it's justified by the
way you maybe we could talk about that,
you know,
income inequality and all those things,
so it's justified anger.
But it seems to me that there are people
of goodwill who need to band together to
diffuse the anger.
Now Society's otherwise we won't have
countries like the United States is the
United States because it's united and
everybody and you've got the United
States,
the American flag there.
You know,
that there's a sense of belonging and
identity and togetherness in a country
in which you've got to preserve.
And so I've stopped.
Actually I'm picking.
I used to,
for example,
quite enjoy picking fights with Deepak
Chopra on twitter and it's just fun to
laugh,
you know,
I need to do
some crazy stuff and he's not.
But I've almost,
I've stopped doing it going well,
but relative to some of the other
people,
it is a,
he's a,
he's,
he's someone who means he means well,
I don't agree with virtually anything he
says.
However,
he's a well meaning person and so I've
started trying to seek common ground
now.
That's why I get,
for example,
gave a talk to the Bishop,
asked me to come here.
I don't agree with them on the
framework,
their theological framework,
but they mean well,
most of them.
Yeah.
So I think seeking consensus and
defeating anger as you said,
is it,
it is incumbent on all of us,
especially people like us who have a
public voice.
We need to diffuse some of this anger
because otherwise it will consume
everyone.
Yes.
I've,
I've tried very hard to evolve in that
respect and just get better at
communicating ideas and get better at
understanding how people receive those
ideas.
And I think that's why it's easy to get
lazy and consult and to.
Yeah,
it's fine.
It's fun.
Especially me.
I mean I'm a comedian as well.
What I do is insult people,
but for humor,
I want to entertain people.
That's the whole idea behind it,
but I think in terms of like discussing
ideas especially that are so personal to
people like religion.
I've,
uh,
I've reexamined the way I interpret
these ideas and the way I talk about
these things.
Yeah,
there's a,
it's interesting.
There's A.
I did a BBC program at age 10.
I was asked to do it on the single reith
lectures at the BBC.
The BBC had done it is 9:52,
I think it was.
Then Robert Oppenheimer did them in 53,
It's fascinating.
You can get the transcripts online.
They're free and you can get one
recording of the five they taped over
the other four.
Can you believe it?
Why they raised them?
Because they wanted to tape something
believable,
but one of them existed oftentimes are
giving these lectures.
Oh my God.
But you can read it just from Katie and
bedroom.
Wrestled him.
The types over them.
Don't read Bertrand Russell's
[inaudible] tape is so expensive,
but he talks crazy,
but he's brilliant.
It's called science in the common
understanding and they weren't very well
received because he thought he was going
to talk about the Manhattan project,
so they thought he was going to talk
about the atom bomb,
you know,
because he was.
He ran it basically,
but he didn't.
He talks about how thinking like a
scientist,
which means thinking in the way that
nature forces you to think can be
valuable in other areas.
And it's a.
that's an insight in itself.
The great thing,
the unique thing about science,
there's nature forces you to think like
that.
You can't have an opinion.
Can I have an opinion about gravity
region with building.
You can hit the ground.
That's it.
It doesn't matter what your opinion is.
And,
and he said,
so if you think about,
for example,
quantum mechanics,
so sometimes you think of as particles
electron,
sometimes it has to.
It's a point like object may behave like
a little billy,
a ball thing.
The pool ball bands is around,
but sometimes it behaves like an
extended thing,
like a wavy thing and nature forces you
to hold both ideas in your head at the
same time in order to get a complete
picture of the object,
the description of an electron.
And he said that's the valuable thing
about quantum mechanics.
You know,
unless you're doing electronics or
inventing lasers and you don't need to
know this stuff,
but if you want to learn how to think
you,
it's valuable to be forced to hold
different ideas in your head.
At the same time.
It's really teaching you not to be an
absolutist straight teaching you the
example he uses his because he was.
I think he was,
had problems with mccarthy and all those
things.
Didn't he say you think he's still.
He's writing in the fifties.
So he said you can either be,
you can be a communist,
which in his definition would be that
you think the needs of the many outweigh
the needs of the few.
Right.
So say societies,
all that matters.
Or it could be a libertarian or right on
the far conservative and where you think
that the individual is the only thing
that matters and that's it,
but actually of course,
to have a functioning society,
you need a mixture of the two and we can
wait it one way or the other,
but you need to hold both ideas in your
head at the same time.
And that's he said that one of the most
valuable things about science because it
forces you into modes of thought that
are valuable.
And that's what we're talking about here
is I'm an absolute.
Physicians are always,
uh,
just a,
a blinkered sort of subsets of what's
actually happening.
You can't understand the world by being
an extremist.
You've got to hold
all these views in your head.
Well that I find that so often on this
podcast because I talk with people I
agree with and disagree with and I
always try to put myself in the head of
the person that I disagree with.
I will always try to figure out how
they're coming to those conclusions are,
where they're coming from.
And I think it's so,
it's so important to not be married to
ideas.
I got a conversation with someone about
this and they said sometimes you change
your opinions a lot.
I go,
yeah,
I do.
Because if it's a bad thing,
like I'm flip flopping.
I'm not a politician,
I'm not flip flopping.
I'm thinking,
yeah,
I'm not sure.
Like I,
I will have one opinion on a thing,
whether it's a controversial thing like
universal basic income and I'll change
my mind 100 percent,
two weeks,
I'll go there and now I think it's
probably a good idea.
And then I'll go back and forth.
No,
no,
no.
People need eight is cruel as it seems.
They need motivation.
They need.
And I don't know,
I bounced around with these things.
Yeah.
But I've tried really hard as I've
gotten older to have less absolute
opinions.
Yeah.
If Richard fineman another great
physicist or a similar,
a similar time to open timer.
And he also went to the Manhattan
project and it's called the value of
science.
I think that was 1955.
And they both shared,
actually a,
a,
a surprise,
I think,
that they were still alive because I
thought that the power they'd given to
the politicians,
the atom bomb would destroy everything
they didn't think that political system
would control it.
And it did.
So that's an emergency.
Malcolm will thing.
We're still here.
But in,
in,
in that essay,
he said the,
um,
the,
the most valuable thing about science is
the realization that we don't know.
And he said,
he said in that statement equals
science.
Satisfactory philosophy of ignorance.
By the way,
you said in that statement is the open
door,
the open channel.
He called it.
So if we want to make progress,
we have to understand that we don't know
everything and we have to leave things
to future generations and we can be
uncertain and we can change our minds.
And he said that,
that,
that is a great last line.
I can't exactly what he says,
but he said something like,
it's our duty as scientists to
communicate the value of uncertainty and
the value of freedom of thought to all
future generations.
That's the point.
That's what freedom means.
Freedom,
it means the freedom to change your
mind.
In fact said,
that's what democracy is.
If you think about it,
democracy is a trial and error system,
so it's the.
It's the admission that we don't know
how to do.
It therefore will change.
Every four years will change.
The president over the eight years will
change the president.
Why?
Because the president doesn't know how
to do it.
Someone better.
There will be someone better that comes
along and then someone worse and someone
better,
but it's a trial and error system and
he's right and it is right that that is
the open door.
That's that.
That's the road to progress is certainly
better than humility.
Yeah.
One of the things that I love so much
about Bertrand Russell and about five
was how human they were.
They were very human means fireman,
like to play the Bongos and chasing
girls and Bertrand Russell was addicted
to tobacco.
He would talk about how he wouldn't fly
unless he could smoke.
Like he had to get us back when they had
smoking sections on airplanes and he had
his pipe and he just refused to fly
without tobacco and couldn't imagine
being without tobacco and like that's so
strange because just a brilliant guy to
be addicted to such a gross thing.
Yeah,
you're right.
Because I think these.
These are people that found existence.
Joyous,
right?
Yeah.
We'll need to know.
They just wanted to know stuff.
Yeah.
I didn't want to know everything because
you can't know everything.
Right.
And I suppose that's what you think
about what the job of a scientist is.
It's to.
It's to stand on the edge of the known
because you're a research scientist,
so if there's nothing to note,
then you've got no job.
Right?
So you have to be naturally comfortable
with not knowing.
And I,
if there's one thing I really do think
we.
How do we begin to patch our countries
back up again?
One of the reasons I think in education
is to teach people the value of
uncertainty,
of not knowing it is not weak to not
know.
It's actually natural not to know.
And that's one of them is with religion,
is to say that you know,
when you do not hard to say that you
have absolute truth and absolute
knowledge of something.
Yeah.
When it can't really exist.
I mean,
history tells us,
doesn't it,
that anyone who thinks they've got
absolute knowledge is a causes trouble.
Yeah.
Did you see x marketer?
Did you enjoy it?
Yes.
I know.
I'm Alex Garland.
Sunshine over.
That was right in 28 days later.
And the new movie,
the Weird One,
the alien movie,
he wrote that as well.
Right?
Um,
dilation and.
Great.
Sandra.
Yeah.
Um,
do you,
are you scared of artificial life?
Artificial intelligence.
And Elan Musk scare the shit out of me.
Yeah.
When he talked about it.
Like he,
he talks about it like we're in the
opening scene of a science fiction movie
where he's trying to warn people and
then they don't listen to the genius.
And it goes south,
sort of depends.
I chaired a debate on this society in
London a few weeks ago and uh,
they.
So it's true now at the moment what
people tend to be frightened of a
general ai's or Agi,
they called artificial general
intelligence,
which is like what we talked about
earlier,
a human like capability thing.
Yes.
Um,
and we're miles away from that.
We don't know how to do it.
We haven't got them and we miles away.
So at the moment artificial intelligence
is expert systems and very focused
systems that do particular things.
You can be scared of them in a limited
economic sense because they're going to
displace people's jobs.
And actually,
interestingly in this panel discussion
we had,
it's going to be like what you might
call middle class jobs in the UK,
so white collar jobs because people are
interested in universal basic income to
sort of replace money that it's going to
be lost because there will be no jobs
for all these people.
Otherwise we have just a mask attached.
Yeah,
they're very good.
Someone said that these systems,
artificial intelligence systems at the
moment are very good at doing things
like law lawyers work.
So they're very good at reading
contracts and things like that.
There's interesting.
It's a revolution,
it's not like the industrial revolution.
Where is manual labor that gets hit
necessarily?
This is kind of interesting because it
hits that kind of intermediate level
that usually escapes.
And so you're right,
one of the answers is to tax.
There was an example was a robot tax.
So in a car factory you say to the
manufacturer,
well,
okay,
you can have a robot,
what you pay the robot the same as you
pay a person and then that money goes
into funding universal basic income or
something like that.
So I think there's got to be an economic
change because these systems will be
there,
but all the experts I spoke to agreed
that the idea of a terminator style,
General Intelligence taking over the
world is miles away.
And um,
so whilst we might start thinking about
the regulation,
it's not going to happen soon,
is the general point.
I think.
So I would disagree with him on that.
I think it's too far in the future at
the moment.
I think it might be one of those people
that's an ad.
It's going to be all right.
And then then,
you know,
my iphone takes me out on the way to
the.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
It's not like choice at the moment,
isn't it?
I mean,
don't,
don't give your phone a laser,
for example.
And it doesn't matter if it goes crazy
and tries to take over the world.
I know,
I know that's a bit facetious because
they can see.
He would say they could take other power
grids and all that kind of stuff.
Well,
it's these concepts that are really hard
to visualize,
like Sora Kurzweil's idea of the
exponential increase of technology
leading us to a point in the near
future.
Where are you going to be able to
download your consciousness into a
computer?
You talked to computer experts.
It like this.
No Way.
We're miles away from that.
Neuroscientists,
scientists.
So you knew one brain cell,
probably we can't,
but Kurzweil's convinced that what's
going to happen is that as technology
increases and increases in this wildly
exponential way where we really can't
visualize it,
we can't even imagine how much
advancement will take place over 50
years.
But in those 50 years,
something's going to happen that
radically changes our idea of what's
possible and I think Elon shares this
idea as well that it's going to sneak up
on us so quickly that when it does go
live,
it'll be too late.
Yeah,
I mean it's worth putting the framework
in place.
I think the regulatory framework,
even as you said,
for the more realistic problem,
which is people's jobs are going to get
displaced and that there's a great,
um,
was at a thing in some segments that I
come in and it was,
but they said that the,
it was a politician that the job of the
innovation system is to create jobs
faster than it destroys them.
So you've always got to remember that as
a government and as regulators,
if you're going to allow technologies
into the marketplace that destroy
people's jobs,
it is your responsibility to find a way
of replacing those jobs or compensate in
those people,
as you said,
for the breakdown,
social,
human being,
those that people need some meaning,
like they just giving them income I
think is just gonna
mean.
It's just my speculation.
But it's going to create massive spare
even if provide them,
you provide them with food and shelter,
they need people need things to do,
so there's going to be some sort of a
demand to find meaning for people,
give them occupations,
give them something,
some task,
let's say.
It seems to be one of the critical parts
of being a person.
So we need things to do that we find
meaning in,
you know,
like you were talking about were the
only things that we know of that have
meaning,
that find meaning and sharing meaning
and believe in that we're gonna need
something like that.
If universal basic income comes along,
I don't think it's going to be enough to
just feed people and house them.
They're gonna want something to do.
If a,
you know,
a person is a,
you're,
you're doing something for an occupation
and this is your identity.
And then all of a sudden that occupation
becomes irrelevant because computer does
it faster,
cheaper,
quicker.
These people are going to have this
incredible feeling of despair and just
not being valuable.
Yeah,
I mean,
uh,
what?
Well,
the utopian.
So the version of this is to everybody
gets to do what we're doing,
now she's make a living.
So thinking and creating that kind of,
you know,
so that that's the Utopian ideal is you
don't need to do the stuff.
The job that you don't really want to do
in the factory,
right?
You can do the thing that humans are
best at that,
but I agree.
That's a very utopian view.
Does everybody want to do that?
Or does everybody have their mindset
will maybe goes to education if
everybody had an interest like that,
if everybody went on to make pottery and
painting and doing all these different
things they've always really wanted to
do and their needs are met by the
universal basic income money that they
receive every month.
But boy,
there's a lot of people I don't think
have those desires or needs and to sort
of force them onto them at age 55 or
whatever it's going to be.
It seems to be very,
very difficult.
Yeah.
I agree.
It's a big challenge,
but I think that in concept at least
it's inevitable that we do have some
sort of an artificial intelligence that
resembles us or that resembles something
like x mark and if people choose to
create that,
we could choose create it in our own
image.
But that's very godlike,
isn't it?
God created us in his own image.
Yeah.
And,
and again,
yeah.
I don't know that when I talk to people
in the field as you probably are,
most of them say don't have to do it.
Yes.
It's really,
it's going to be miles away,
so maybe I'm hiding my head in the sand
a bit,
but I don't think so.
I think it's.
I think we'll know it when I don't think
anyone's going to do it accidentally,
so I don't think it's just suddenly
going to be upon us.
I,
I think we will see it will,
we will see ourselves getting,
acquiring that capability.
We'll see ourselves getting close.
We'll see their systems beginning to
emerge and then we will think about it.
I think 200 years ago,
if you wanted a photograph or something,
you want a picture of something you had
to draw.
I
mean,
there was no photography 200 years ago.
Yeah,
I mean just think of that is almost
inconceivable.
No automobiles,
no photography.
What was automobile?
Maybe there was some sort of machines
that drove people around.
Right?
Something close.
There was earlier than that,
right?
You go back 500 years,
you have almost nothing.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
How are we being quick?
So fast.
It's so fast.
I mean,
and then this,
what we're doing right now,
there's people right now in their car
that are streaming this,
so they're in their car and they're
listening as they're driving on the
road.
Maybe they have a tesla,
maybe they have an electric car.
They're driving down the road streaming
to people talking where it's ones and
Zeros that are broken down and there's
some audible form and you can listen to
it in your car.
That is
bananas.
Yeah,
I agree.
We've been quick so quick.
Well,
I think that they will,
you know,
the Internet.
I mean,
it's uh,
not long.
I mean I remember it being invented.
Well certainly the web,
so the web,
while it was very early for me because I
was in the,
in particle physics and of course the
web comes from certain,
the www bit,
right.
So it certainly in the early nineties I
was involved in that,
um,
you know,
in,
in the university environment with email
and all that kind of stuff.
So I don't,
I don't know when it kind of didn't
really.
You could have,
you could have a web browser that just
the only sites that were there and Nasa
and uh,
I think NASA edited one of the early
sites and cern.
It was very loud.
When did you become involved with siren?
So that would be.
I started doing particle physics in 95.
And when was,
when did the large Hadron collider go
live?
That was,
um,
I remember it was 2000 and
2007.
I think he was 2008 is so long ago.
That was about 10 years ago.
But he started out,
we started off and then we had a problem
with it and then it took a while to fix.
Um,
so hasn't been taking data that long,
but it's a tremendously successful thing
now and it's,
it's operating beyond this design
capabilities.
It's quite incredible.
And so stunning is an incredible thing
that this,
I mean,
how large is it?
How long has the largest is 27
kilometers.
So I'd say about 16 miles.
Sixteen miles.
And it's a circular.
Yeah,
sort of a building.
Yeah.
Well,
I say it's a big tube and mean you think
basically it's mainly under France and
partly into Switzerland and he
accelerates protons around in a circle
both ways that won't.
One beam goes well.
My one goes either way and they go round
11,000 times a second because that's the
very close.
The speed of light.
90 nine point nine,
nine,
nine percent.
The speed of light.
And then we crossed the beams and
collide the particles.
And in those collisions you're
recreating the conditions that were
present or less than a billionth of a
second after the big bang.
So we know that physics,
so going back,
reset about the carbon and the oxygen,
we can trace that story back way beyond
the time when they were protons and
neutrons to when they were quarks and
gluons around and go all the way back
and the Higgs on doing its thing back
then and so we can see all that physics
in the lab.
So that's why we have some,
a lot of confidence in that story.
It's so fascinating that they were able
to talk someone into funding that,
that they got a bunch of people together
and that you,
you were able to explain to politicians
and,
and you know,
regular people,
what,
what you're trying to do.
He a great example of how you get
something done.
So it was the night in the fifties when
certain was established,
I think it was 53 or 54,
can't quite remember it.
Something like that.
And um,
it was bill from the Second World War,
so at the end of the war and it was
realized that the only way forward for
Europe was collaboration to rebuild the
scientific base and in,
for peace for peaceful purposes.
And so certain was set up as an
international collaboration in Europe
initially with that political ideal that
it would,
it would explore nature,
uh,
just for,
for the,
for freely and for peace,
for peaceful means,
peaceful reasons.
And so that was,
uh,
the,
the politics was right.
So we set it by international treaty so
that the member states are bound
together by a treaty and they pay a
small amount,
relatively small amount each into
certain every year,
which is a percentage of their GDP.
And that's the money they used to build
the experiments and build the
accelerators.
So it's very hard to get out of it.
And you wouldn't really want to because
it's a small amount of money per country
and stern doesn't get extra money to
build things.
It just takes his money and basically
saved up and plans itself.
But because it's got a regular stream of
money,
it can do it so you can say we're going
to build this machine and it will take
eight years because that's how much
money we've got now,
mobility in eight years and we know how
much money we've got so we can do it
you.
It's less than.
I mean the reason that the US collider,
the SSC failed is because it's the
problem you have in the us with the
funding system as you've seen in the
last few weeks,
is that it's very arbitrary and it's
open to political maneuvering and things
can be shut down and take an uncertain
is not like that.
Cerner has got a guaranteed stream of
funding small from each country and so
you can do these projects.
And the one in the US that was during
the Clinton administration is.
I would.
It was a.
yeah,
it was.
It was it Clinton.
It was closed down by Congress and a
very slim vote and it was in Texas,
so it was.
It was one of those things where you've
got states vying for money and he was
half built and everyone was there,
you know,
the thing,
it was bigger than the LHC and it was
Thursday.
So you waste a lot of money.
Is that a huge disappointment for
scientific community?
Like where people very hopeful that this
was going to go live.
It was being built.
So it doug,
half the tunnel.
What would it be able to do that?
The LHC could.
It was a higher energy accelerated in
the LHC.
So it would have discovered the higgs
particle first.
Uh,
had it been running,
but the,
the half bill part,
is it useless now or can they charge it
up again now?
I think they filled in.
I think so.
I mean it was just half a tunnel,
you know,
that's the thing.
You can do these wonderful things for
not a lot of money if you just do it
over many years now.
Stable funding.
Yeah.
Commit to doing it.
The filling in,
in part slurry.
And you look at cern as well,
and people.
Yeah.
People ask me now,
I think the UK pays about $100,000,000 a
year.
That's what the UK pays in and it's
about St Germany,
same two friends and so on.
And so people say,
what do we get for that?
I mean,
first of all,
it's not the whole budget seven is about
the same as a budget of a medium sized
university.
So it's not a lot.
It's about a billion dollars a year or
something,
which is what a university has.
So there's not a lot in the scheme of
things.
Um,
what has it done though?
Well,
we invented the World Wide Web,
as we've just said,
a lot of the medical imaging technology
that we use comes from cern,
is pioneered the use of these very high
field magnet switch is what it needed.
So it's engineering at the edge and
engineering at the edge generates
spinoffs and expertise to get used in
other fields.
So it's cancer treatment,
so called Hadron beam therapy.
So if you got a brain tumor now,
it's quite likely that you'll have one
of these targeted particle beam
therapies,
which is like very highly targeted sort
of chemotherapy.
It's not chemotherapy radiation you can
target in a beam into your head and
attack the tumor and those,
those are particle accelerators.
So most pathway accelerators today here
in hospitals and in medicine,
but they came from doing particle
physics that.
So the,
the,
the of these big experiments at the edge
of our capability are always immense,
which is why they're worth funding at
these very low levels.
But it's not just the knowledge,
it's the engineering expertise that
there is a practical application for
every everyday.
They're always,
it's just finding out how to do hard
things is usually useful.
The moral,
and it wasn't just the Higgs Boson
particle that you guys had discovered.
What is cork glue on plasma?
Yeah.
So that,
that's um,
shortly after the billionth of a second,
after the big bang.
So you end up with a soup of quarks and
gluons quarks are the building blocks of
protons and neutrons and glue onto the
things that stick them together.
And so a proton as to up quarks and down
quark and in each and stu down quarks
and up quark and so on,
so that the constituents,
the protons and neutrons,
which are their constituents of our
atomic nuclei and savy go if you get to
very high temperatures,
are high energies,
then the protons and neutrons falter
bits.
Then you end up with a soup of quarks
and gluons that's acquired gluon plasma.
And it's insanely dense,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
very high energy.
So,
um,
so you get that.
So we've been exploring that bite.
Could we.
We don't only collide protons together,
we can collide a lead nuclei together or
silver nuclei together at the LHC and
that's when you make these kind of suit,
civil nuclear matter,
if you like,
very hot nuclear matter to explore that
physics to that and that nuclear
physics.
And I was reading something about the
weight of that stuff that like a sugar
cube.
Like what,
what is the,
what is the actual weight,
where defends our density is.
So don't they?
I mean,
the,
the thing I remember is the sugar cube
of a neutron star material,
which is,
I don't know how many hundred million
tons I can,
you know,
it depends,
but.
So I don't know where the quite glum
plasma.
I don't know what number you're.
There was something that was one of the
things after the discovery they were
talking about the massive weight of
court gluon plasma in like almost
incomprehensible.
Yeah.
I don't know the number but,
but something crazy.
Yeah.
Now one,
once these,
you got something.
Oh,
here it is.
Forty billion million.
Oh my God.
A cubic centimeter would weigh 40
billion tons.
Oh,
good Lord.
I didn't know that.
I don't know David actually.
Yeah.
The dentist matter.
Creating the big bang machine.
What are they doing right now?
It's clothes for engineering and
upgrades and upgrades.
Yeah.
I mean,
one thing we trying to do is one of the
things in particle physics is that you
want as many collisions per second as
you can generate and um,
they have a collision wherever.
What's got a bunch crossing Lhc,
we can vary,
but it's something like 25 Nano seconds
depending on what it's really.
We get a lot of collisions per second
and the more collisions per second you
can get,
the more chance you have a make an
interest in things like higgs particles
or whatever else may be out there
waiting to be discovered.
I mean,
it's possible there are other particles
out there that we haven't yet discovered
that could be within the reach of the
LHC and if this one that was in Texas
had gotten built and it was more
powerful than the Lhc,
you'd have even more opportunity to do
something like that.
Yeah.
Now when these things are created by
these collisions,
how long do they last?
Oh,
fractions of a second.
So that the general rule in physics and
particle physics is that the more
massive it is and the more things it can
decay into,
the faster it'll do that.
And so basically the,
the heavy things decay into light things
and so the only.
The stable particles,
things like electrons
and some of the quarks and the up quarks
and down quarks is stable things.
But uh,
so,
so everything tends to decay very fast.
So we're talking fractioned billions of
a second fractions.
And how are they less than that?
How are they registering it's existence.
Like what is,
what is being used to measure it?
So what you see if you collide the adhc
we collide protons together,
then president,
I've got loads of stuff in them,
loads of gluons quarks.
So yeah,
big mess.
First of all.
So most of it's a load of particles or
spray now we should not interested in.
But sometimes when you,
when let's say a couple of the glue on
was banging together and they can make
something interesting like a top quark
or a higgs particle.
What's a top court?
It's not quite,
it's a very heavy.
There's six quarks.
So there's up and down chairman,
strange bottom and top farm and strange.
So strange was literally in the,
was it the fifties I discovered them.
Someone said that's really strange and
strange and new kind of farcical.
And so yes,
we have six quarks and they're in three
families,
so the up and down or one family,
and then the chairman,
stranger,
another family in the top and bottom of
the third family.
And so we for some reason,
so the only thing the only fast because
we need to make up you and me are up
quarks down quarks and electrons,
but for some reason there are two
further copies of those which are
identical in every way except they're
heavier.
So there's the charm and the strange
quark and if they're in a heavy electron
called immune,
and then there's a the top and the
bottom quark and another heavy electron
call the tail.
And that's it.
So that there's this weird pattern that
we don't understand.
So we don't.
Seems like you only needed the first
family to build a universe.
Right?
But for some reason there are two copies
now when the heavy ones decay into the
lighter ones is the point.
So when you make them,
they're not around very long.
And just answer your question,
what happens is that when they decay,
throw their decay products out into our
detector.
So we take a photograph of the cascade
of particles that comes from these
heavier particles decaying,
and the trick is to patch it all,
look to see,
to try and work out where everything
came from.
Wow.
Now when they finally find these
unexpected particles,
then what happens?
Then there's the study of them.
Then there's the and everybody gets
together and go,
okay,
what the hell is that?
Yeah,
what does that,
what do we do?
So we want to know where the Higgs
particle.
We know what it does is it gives them
access to everything.
So it's fundamentally the thing that
gives mass to all the other things in
the universe at the most fundamental
level.
So,
so electrons for example,
and the up and down quarks.
And again,
a mess from their interaction with the
Higgs.
That's why they're massive.
That's another reason we exist.
You know,
we go way back.
We wouldn't exist if there wasn't mass
in the universe.
And the Higgs is ultimately responsible
for that mess.
And I keep saying,
I keep caveat in it because then you get
other sorts of masks that are generated,
but,
but that the fundamental basic seed is
it where is from is from the Higgs and
so what we want to know is we want to
know how that thing behaves and the way
you want to study it.
So you want to make a lot of them so you
can take a lot of pictures of it and
study it a lot and see exactly how it
does that.
And so that's what we're doing.
That's what we're engaged in at the
moment.
We're making high precision measurements
of the way that particle behaves so we
can understand the laws of nature.
I mean that that is the laws of nature.
How are those particles behave and what
are they doing.
But it is possible that some new form of
some new form of particles,
something else could be discovered.
Yeah.
The we know about yet because we know
almost know that there,
there are other particles out there in
the universe.
We almost.
No,
because I think called dark matter.
Yes.
So we look out into the universe and we
see that there's a lot of stuff there
that's interacting,
gravitation Italy,
but he's not interacting strongly with
the matter out of which we are made and
the stars are made.
So it,
it,
it's almost certain that that some form
of particle that that fits beautifully
and we see lots of different
observations the way galaxies rotate and
interact and even the oldest light in
the universe,
the so called cosmic microwave
background radiation,
we see the signature of that stuff in
that light as well.
So we think that there's some of the
particle out there and to be honest,
we thought we would have detected it.
I think at Lhc we have lots of theories
called supersymmetric theories that make
predictions for all sorts of different
particles that would interact weekly
with normal matter.
And I.
Yeah,
I think it's broadly seen as a surprise
that we haven't seen them the LAC.
So that just may well mean that either
they're very,
they're a bit too massive,
so we need more energy to make them.
And we just haven't quite got enough.
Oh,
we're not making enough of them often
enough to see them,
which is one of the reasons we're great
in the LHC.
So we also looked for them by the way,
I'm directly,
so we have experiments and the
mountains,
we bury them in the,
in,
so the cosmic rays from space don't
interfere with them.
And we're looking for the rare occasions
when these dark matter particles bumpin.
So the particles of matter in the
detector,
so it,
so the idea would be this room's full of
them.
I mean the galaxy is swimming with that
matter as far as we can tell,
but interacts very weakly with this
matter so it doesn't bump into us very
often.
So we're looking for the direct
detection of it and we're looking to
make those particles lhc.
So it's everywhere,
but it doesn't interact with us very
weakly.
Um,
so interacts with the gravity and the,
the,
the archetype or particle that's
everywhere.
That doesn't interact strongly as a
neutrino.
So we do know about neutrinos.
We've detected those.
And there there is something like 60
billion per centimeter squared per
second passing through your head.
Now from the sun,
so they get made in nuclear reactions in
the sun,
but they go straight through your head
and then straight through the earth,
pretty much occasionally one of them
bumps into something and we can detect
those cars were so many of them are
going through,
but we only,
you know,
I don't know,
one or two a day.
And the ideas that dark matter
encompasses an enormous percentage of
the universe.
Yes,
it's five times as much matter is dark
matter than is normal matter and the
number is 25 percent of the universe.
So it's roughly speaking,
but five percent of the university's
normal matter stars in gas,
25 percent is dark matter.
Yeah.
So that.
Yeah,
five,
no amount.
About 25 dark matter and about 70 is
dark energy.
That's the other thing.
The other thing,
yeah.
So what the hell is that?
I don't know know what it does.
So again,
what we talked about Einstein's theory
earlier.
So Einstein's theory,
which works spectacularly well,
says that if you put stuff into the
university,
we said before,
then he walks and deforms and stretches
and it very precisely telogy given the
stuff that you put in it,
how much does it stretch and how does it
stretch and the the measurement we have
is how stretching.
So so we we observed the thing we
observe is how the universe is expanding
and how the expansion rate is changing
and how excited and how it's changed
over time.
So we have very precise measurements of
that.
So then we can use this theory to tell
us what's in it given that we know what,
how it's responding to that stuff.
And that's how we discovered dark
energy.
So we noticed that the university is
expansion rate is increasing.
So university accelerating in its
expansion,
which is exactly the opposite of what we
thought and this is in the 19 nineties
that we discovered that so we can work
out what sort of stuff and how much of
that stuff you need to put in the
universe to make that happen.
And that's where we get these numbers
from.
And was there resistance to that when
that was first proposed?
Yeah,
I'm in it.
My,
one of my friends that Brian Schmidt and
got the Nobel prize for that.
And um,
I remember I talked to him and he said,
uh,
he was a Postdoc,
I think at the time,
so young researcher and he made it.
He's making measurements of Supernova,
the light from supernova explosions,
which is so bright that you can see
them,
you know,
hundreds of million,
billions of light years away.
And he noticed that if you look at the
data,
the light is stretched in the wrong way.
So we look at the stretch of light as it
travels across the universe and the
universe is expanding.
It stretches the lights so it changes
the color.
And he noticed that there was a
discrepancy,
which we said that the universe,
that the expansion rate is speeding up.
It's been speeding up from,
I think something like 7 billion years
old.
So it's been speeding up.
Um,
so he thought that he's done something
wrong because it,
you know,
so,
so he checked it and checked it and
checked it and he couldn't find anything
wrong,
so he did what a good scientist does,
which he published it so that somebody
else could find out what he'd done
wrong.
And he said that he thought it would be
the end of his career.
He thought I'd be a laughing stock and
he got the Nobel prize because he was
right.
It is stretch.
Wow.
It's a great lesson.
Means that if you,
if you're sure that you can't see what
you've done wrong,
then you publish.
It goes back to that thing about
humility we talked about earlier.
You know what we ultimately,
we're not trying to be right.
We're trying to find out stuff and so
they're a good scientists will be really
happy if they set out to be wrong
because they've learned something now.
That's the,
that's the,
it's good that you take that path
because he got the Nobel prize now when
he received the Nobel prize in this
concept started being discussed,
what was the initial reaction to it?
Well,
it's,
it's interesting because it's allowed in
Einstein's theory and it was in
Einstein's original theory,
so it's called,
it's got a name,
it's called the cosmological constant,
and that's,
um,
it's,
it just allowed in the equations.
And Einstein actually introduced it,
um,
initially to,
because Einstein's equations strongly
suggests that the universe is expanding
or contracting and not just sat there.
So even before we'd observed anything,
Einstein had a theory that suggested
that the university just not static and
actually really strongly suggest that
there's a beginning,
right?
So the,
the theory itself on its own suggests
that you can see if the university is
stretching today,
that he must've been smaller in the
past.
Right now,
everything must have been closer
together.
Let's say that,
um,
so that,
as a man magical George Lemaitre,
who was a,
who works independently of Einstein,
but the same time in the early 19
twenties before we even knew there were
other galaxies beyond the Milky Way.
And they notice that the,
the equation suggests the universe might
be stretching.
Um,
and so he wrote to Einstein and said,
your theory suggests there was a day
without a yesterday because he thought
if everything's expanding now,
then it must've been closer together in
the past and so there might be a time
when it was all together and he was a
priest.
So it's a Belgian priest.
So I think,
I mean I wrote about this now it's kind
of mindset a bit,
but I think that he was more predisposed
to accept what the equations were
telling him because a beginning,
an origin for priest is really a nice
thing because it tells you the creation
event,
it's an Einstein try to dodge it and put
this allowed term into his equation,
which is the,
almost the stretchy tube.
So say,
well if it's old,
if it's all kind of contract in or
something,
can I put something in to make it
stretch a bit to balance it all out so
it can be eternal and you can't,
you can't make it eternal that way,
but eat.
So he tried it,
they took it out and cold it.
His biggest blunder,
taking it,
putting it in his biggest funder,
or at least some people think what he'd
done was missed the prediction of the
big bang.
Really.
So by trying to fiddle around to have a
static universe that stable,
he missed what the equations were
screaming.
His own theory was screaming to him,
which is that no,
the universe expands or contracts and he
missed it.
Right?
So I think that's probably what he meant
by biggest blunder,
but in any case he took it out and then
later in the 19 nineties it turns out
the notes there,
but it's really small.
It's tiny,
tiny effect,
but it's still dominating the universe
now and it will,
it will dominate even more in the
future.
So we think that we're in the universe
that will continue to expand essentially
doubling in size,
a fixed timescale in which is about 20
billion years.
So within every 20 billion years into
the future forever,
unless something happens,
the universe will continue to expand and
double in size to you.
And that's the dark energy is driving
them,
but nobody knows what it is.
It's the,
it's one of the cutting edge,
massive problems in theoretical physics
and what is being done to try to get a
better grasp of what it is.
Um,
and it's theoretical.
I mean we're making very precise
observations of it,
right?
But it looks like this constant,
so it looks like it's basically one a
number,
if you like,
in Einstein's equations and just really
simple.
So it looks like it's something that may
be a property of space itself,
I don't know,
but it looks like a very simple thing
that doesn't change over time and just
stays there so,
so it requires theoretical advance as
well.
And so people are trying very hard to,
to do that.
It's so crazy when you go from Galileo
to modern theoretical physics that
they're still in the midst of this
understanding of what all this stuff is.
Yeah,
I mean these,
uh,
you know,
these are fundamental and difficult
problems and we're talking about the
origin and evolution of the universe.
That's what it is and it,
and tell us a particle physics.
I mean,
the way that these things,
this stuff,
we keep talking about this stuff in the
universe,
that's what the lhc studies he studies
had the stuff behaves right now.
These are,
it's very theoretical,
right?
They're trying to wrap their minds
around what this is and what the
properties of it or do you envision a
time where you can actually physically
measure this and,
and have a,
a,
a real clear understanding of what it is
and what its properties.
Dark energy and I don't know.
Um,
I mean,
for example,
there are theories,
which should probably not right,
but they're not necessarily wrong here.
There are theories that try to link it
to the Higgs particle.
So the Higgs particle which we've
discovered and can measure has some
properties that we think the dark energy
would need.
And I'll this inflation I mentioned way
back at the start of the universe,
it has some of the properties that can
do that as well.
So for example,
there are faithfully tries to link them.
So we do have an observation of the
higgs.
We can study that.
So are they linked?
Don't know.
Um,
but so it could be that we can study it
even though it's a very small weak
effects and it could be web direct
access.
Food is great.
I mean it's just these are big mysteries
that there's something really profound
we don't understand about the way that
stuff in particular.
The Higgs actually interacts with space
and time.
So very naively the higgs should blow
the universe apart just very naively.
It's loads of energy in a very small
amount of space and huge amounts of
energy and the higgs field,
but it doesn't do anything apart from
giving to things.
It doesn't seem to me it doesn't
directly affect space,
but everything else that you put in
space directly affects it.
So,
you know,
there are,
there are kind of issues there that we
don't and it just says we don't get it.
We don't,
we don't get it yet.
It's just another one of those.
They probably late there.
I,
if I was to guess,
I'd say there's some link there,
you know,
there's something going on and solving
one of them might solve the other two
inflation higgs dark energy something.
How many people worldwide would you
estimate are trying to grasp this and,
and working on this?
A good question.
I don't know.
I mean it's a,
it's probably tens if that is tens of
thousands,
if you count all the people who work at
cern and the particle physicists and a
theoretical physicists,
it'd be tens of thousands because
it's,
it's so important to,
for us to get an understanding of what's
going on,
but yet so outside of the grasp of most
people including me,
like I'm listening to you talk about
this and I'm like,
thank God there's people like you thank
whatever,
thank quirks because people like you out
there that are doing this,
but it,
it's almost like you're speaking another
language.
It's so strange to me.
Well,
it's very new stuff,
you know,
I mean,
even when I was at school and so when I
was at university,
we hadn't discovered the top quark and
we knew it was there.
We thought the Higgs might be there,
but we had no idea whether it was,
you know,
so,
so we were moving in my career,
we're moving quite fast.
Um,
and yet you're right,
these are the most fundamental questions
about what,
why is there ultimately why is the
universe the way it is and even possibly
why is there a universe right where we
were away from that yet,
but if we're ever going to answer that,
it will be by doing stuff like this and
this is all addressed in this live show
that you're doing this world live show
and certainly the,
they also the consequences of the not
the country has had knowledge,
but the cosmology is terrifying that as
we've started with.
And so I think it,
as we've said it,
it raises questions.
It makes quite vivid questions that we
all have about,
you know,
what are,
what are we doing here like this?
So I try and I think this goes all the
way back to me.
I'm really been into Carl Sagan.
He always used to try this.
You try,
you try to link it to things that people
think about naturally.
Then that's why people are fascinated by
this stuff because they do actually
think about it.
It might not be with the right names,
the right words or the right facts even,
but they're thinking about how did I get
here,
how did I come to exist,
what is the future?
Do we have a future?
What was our past year?
These,
these are universal questions.
I think there certainly are and the way
you're doing this with your live show,
you were saying that you have an
enormous visual aspect to it as well.
We have a.
we,
we have the biggest screen we can get in
every venue and it's led.
It's one of the state of the art modern
led screen,
so they're like Lego and you can build
them so you fill the venue with it so
you know at Wembley arena than it's 30
meters wide by eight meters high.
It's enormous.
You must have a huge crew carrying all
this stuff for 16 or 18 people and it's
like a rock and roll show.
Some of the venues,
we do it in North America that in Canada
that there are a bit smaller venues,
but we just fill it with screen as much
as we can get.
And then the graphics,
a lot of the graphics I,
I have were done by a day neg who did x
Makena actually an interstellar.
And the reason I chose,
I chose them,
I rang them up and goes,
please,
please will you do this.
And they said,
which one have you got?
And you know,
because it's way lower than Chris Nolan.
Yeah,
they did it.
They were really,
they just liked the idea of these
messages and these ideas.
So they,
they use the software that they use for
interstellar to create images of black
holes and they use general relativity.
They coded it into the so that graphic
software,
so they can rate trace lights around
black holes and you can move the camera
around the black hole and it traces the
way or the light moves around it.
So if you remember those amazing,
the Gargantua,
the black hole interstellar,
that's,
that's a simulation.
It's not an artist's impression,
is a simulation of what Einstein's
theory tells us a black coal will look
like.
And so I can use that to talk about what
happens when you fall into a black hole.
What would you see watching someone fall
in and you can explain all that using
Einstein's theory now,
the idea that it's kind of a well known
idea.
It's a bizarre idea that if,
if I was to fall into a black hole and
you were watching,
you'd never seen me fall in.
You'd see time slow down my time,
slow down as you watched me.
So in the end I just slow down,
slow down,
and then I get frozen on the event
horizon and just fade away as an image
or reddening image on the event horizon.
So time passes at different rates as you
move closer to the black hole and
faraway because space and time of
distorted by the mass of the black hole.
And so I can I talk about all that,
but I talk about all that with this
incredible image which we had.
It's so high resolution by the way that
they.
It was higher resolution than they're
used for interstellar cause my screen's
so big so we need a special machine to
play it.
You can buy the most expensive Mac pro
in the world and it will not play this
stuff.
I love that.
From a Geek perspective,
brilliant.
You have to have a special video player
to play the damn thing.
It was just like a series of CPU is all
attached together in some sort of a
super cute.
Yeah.
It's one of those is a big sort of
visualization graphics.
Things were,
but these files,
like you know,
they don't.
Twenty gig video files because there's
so many pixels.
The pixels.
This is really geeky in it.
The fix the regulation.
Six thousand 400 by 15,
36,
seven screens.
It's a lot.
Yeah,
it's a lot.
They're huge files.
Are you coming to Los Angeles with this?
When the Taliban theater in May,
the end of May.
I'm there if I'm here or there it.
Oh yeah,
no,
you got to come 24th of May.
Oh,
you're in San Diego as well today.
I got to see one of these.
Go to one of the.
It's going to be great fun and however
much stuff we can fit into those two
handsome devil,
look at that.
Nice jacket on.
Looking good.
So yeah,
someone gave me that actually of.
Well,
it's cool because cool guy.
Cool guy with space behind you.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's awesome
man.
Well listen,
thank you so much for doing this.
I really appreciate you.
Appreciate everything you're doing so
awesome.
No,
thank you.
I always enjoy [inaudible].
I loved it last time and people still
talk about it when I was on last time.
The more people ask me about meeting you
than virtually anybody else will say get
rid of because it's like 100 times more
popular than it was back then.
It's going to be very strange now,
but thank you again.
Really appreciate it.
I can't wait to see your show.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Bye everybody.